Chad, help me, I'm developing an unhealthy obsession with these
people who have an unhealthy obsession with Hutch's unhealthy
obsession. Hey, we can solve both of our issues at the same time.
We can actually feed this beast on both ends right now. I have
a totally insane obsession with Hutch. >> If you want a
new TV, like what does that look like? If there's no currency,
do you just like go to the Best Buy and just pick it off the
shelf and that's it? Or how does that how does THAT WORK?
>> IS SOMEBODY JUST TYPING to him or something? If Mister
Girl was watching this, he would lose his mind, okay? Have the
conversation you came here to have or don't have a conversation.
We're going to do some drama stuff first. This is the start of
straight-up Hutch, okay? Um I don't even know what
disagreeing about. I feel like I see you a bit in the live and
learn chat disagreeing with me.
Oh, yeah. Everyone, last night Did he just wink or was that just
the >> and learn chat disagreeing with me.
Oh, yeah. I feel like I see you a bit in the live and learn Okay,
that's funny. That's like an Aspen Gold thing. >> disagreeing
with me.
Oh, yeah.
I don't even I don't even know what that was supposed to indicate.
That I don't even know That's just funny, man. That's just funny
to me. >> Last night all y'all were pissing me off just
in different ways, but many such cases. Then I'll start with
um
What was it? Okay, so it seems like a big a big like impetus
for your conversation with Lycan with some of the stuff that
you were saying on the episode with with Rashad. You can't look
at the future and say, "Well, I don't know what's going to happen,
so I'm not going to be proactive." You be proactive where you
can and you let the the chips fall where they may. You're missing
the part where they won and then did a bunch of evil stuff. To
do the evil [__] you got to win. I'm asking you.
Dude, What do you do? No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no. This is a thing of I'm asking when in a reality it's
like, "Well, I don't really agree." No, you said target Fox News
like Democratic >> I MEAN? SEND THE liars that you can
prove have lied to jail. FOR WHAT? LYING WHAT ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT? >> FOR AIDING AND ABETTING A CONSPIRACY against
the United States of America knowingly. Dude, sounds a lot like
MAGA right now. Right? And I I think the thing that stood out
to me is lately I've noticed you on this like big like we have
to be kind of like really really stand true and committed to
liberalism, liberal principles, and these are going to be the
sorts of things I don't know if I want to like pause to look
at his chat as we go along.
She's so annoying.
Hutch is going to devour Hutch, okay? Uh, what? that give us
the tools to help resist Trump um adequately, and we don't want
to lose sight of those things just because we're like trying
to, you know, oppose like encroaching fascism in this
And I don't disagree with you that like
like these are like the times of panic or the times of like the
most uh political instability can be the times where people feel
like in order to
adequately resist
Not so Erudite is in is in the side chat arguing for
Hutch right now. It's very funny. the poli- There's just lots
of lots of examples of her coming in and arguing for Hutch.
It's all of them. EVEN IF THEY'RE NICE. WE GOT TO GET ALL THESE
WE GOT A MOVEMENT THAT THEY FEEL IS endangering their country,
they themselves can engage in behaviors that are unprincipled,
illiberal,
that will just be like a race to the bottom. So, in that respect
with you, like I share that concern, but I don't I don't really
get that sense from Rashad, even if I didn't really agree with
all of the things that he was prescribing as far as actions that
like Dems or Dems need to take to oppose MAGA. But, I think the
the biggest thing was towards the end you said like like
No. GET OUT OF OUR TENT.
Not so Erudite worked in Progressive Victory with Straight A
Aid, okay? Literally working towards electing Democratic candidates
with straight raid like a year ago, like a year and a half ago.
They worked together in the same pack to get DEMOCRATS ELECTED.
GET OUT OF OUR TENTS. GET OUT OF OUR TENTS. SHUT THE [__]
UP. It's so fake and performative, man. It's crazy.
You're You're saying that you're getting like authoritarian authoritarian
tendencies almost like revolutionary vibes from this guy and
that you don't like that because it's important to uphold the
little order. But then when you you were asked about the Iran
strikes and you were like, "Well, that didn't work out so badly
like when it happened all those months ago. So like I guess it's
not it's not that bad." And that just immediately was a massive
contradiction to me because the power to declare war resides
with Congress and Trump taking those actions even if they had
netted better outcomes than what they did to me should be like
a huge red flag to you and they just didn't seem to be. Maybe
you can reconcile this for me though. I guess I'm not understanding
the contradiction cuz like I don't talk a lot about foreign policy
stuff cuz I don't really know a lot about foreign policy stuff.
I couldn't tell you what legal authorization Trump used to do
the strike unilaterally. I'm not sure if there are a lot of people
that took the view that what he did in Iran was unconstitutional.
Maybe there are those kinds of people, but um like I can be opposed
to
I mean I think like the recent strikes are a better example of
this because I opposed the recent strikes because this I think
is just a significant escalation. There's a really significant
kind of risk of war.
Kev99GH was once once on stream, right? Yeah, I'm guessing DGG
is watching this at this point and they're typing in the chats
a lot. Um >> It is what it is. [clears throat] And um obviously
like I was like a young adult when Iraq happened and so like
all of that is very vivid vivid in my mind. Uh What I'm guessing
happened here is that there's a conversation happening and Hutch
is getting his head caved in and then basically they start the
conversation over about an hour from now with a lot of people
participating in chat giving Hutch's arguments. I'm I'm guessing.
Now, maybe not cuz I think Aaron would probably try to be nice
to him here, but I'm guessing that's what's going to happen cuz
they say round two, like restarting for round two a little bit
later. And I'm like, okay, it's going to be with a lot of people
there to try to give Hutch arguments that he could use instead
of just watching um instead of just watching or responding. He's
Hutch needs his chat to argue for him all the Uh but as far as
the strikes go on the facilities,
I was very nervous the first day,
but even then I thought to myself, okay, if I play this tape
out and this doesn't really escalate into any kind of war, I
think it this is probably going to be like slightly popular for
Donald Trump, but people aren't really going to think about it
or talk about it too much. And that's pretty much what
Uh then I guess I would encourage you to take a more firm stance
against it, both the ones that happened last year and the ones
that just occurred now, because the reason why you said that
the you're more opposed to the ones that happened recently is
because you think it's like it's contributing to a significant
increase for the risk of war, which I'd argue like him doing
that, like even the New York Times is referring to this like
as a war of choice. Like it is already a war. Whether or not
we're going to like feel the effects domestically is going to
depend on how much uh they're going to Oh, you could have feel
the effects domestically.
>> You are feeling the hardcore feeling the effects domestically,
okay? You guys are
Okay? We are all You have no idea. You have no idea. The Strait
of Hormuz is shut down.
Europe is going to enter a massive energy crisis. lean into like
mobilizing troops, if they're going to seek any sort of congressional
authorization to divert funds, or however like if they need more
spending and they're not able to just use it um through like
executive action or whatever. But I would say that unambiguously
both of both actions in both instances
were absolutely extra like not constitutional.
It and it is the reason why Democrats are scrambling in both
instances to vote on the war power. So Hutch is basically sorry,
Aaron is basically arguing that this is a sign of fascism, too.
This is illiberal from their on their part. They're committing
illiberal actions and Hutch isn't saying I don't really criticize
that cuz I don't know about foreign policy. So the foreign policy
element it's like you should probably learn enough to know whether
or not this is okay because this is a huge illiberal mark against
that party. >> because they're trying to rein in the president
but like there was no reason especially after the pretense being
last time that oh, we need to completely destroy the nuclear
facilities. Well, if you bragged and said that they've been completely
obliterated like what is the reason and justification for this?
And to me I think like I would encourage you to take a more principled
stand against that because I don't think you should solely evaluate
whether or not you support it based off the out if it gets an
outcome that's neutral to favorable. You should probably just
always start from the position that like no, it it is way way
way too much of an overreach of executive power and authority
if we are going to just put up with the president taking unilateral
actions that are amount to declarations of war. Whether that
be a Democratic president or Republican president. >> is
this is Hutch saying I believe Hutch's position in the Venezuelan
stuff on the Venezuela stuff was well, it worked out really well
so I support it,
Basically like politically you should support it because it worked
out really well. And it's like one, you don't even know the downstream
effects. Like you could say Iraq worked out really well within
the first couple days of the Iraq war, right? It looks like it
goes really
Um so I'm I mean I am principally opposed to both the strikes.
It was just in in the case of the first strike it was just more
of um
I think that's like the second certainly the second round of
strikes I think are the consequences of that are much much much
more extreme. The situation is like much much much more incendiary
and the way that I've talked about the first instance where they
got the nuclear facility I've described it as kind of like well,
this is just like a optics W for the president. Um you know,
a slight majority of the country I think, found their way to
approving those strikes and um, it didn't feel like something
that Americans really cared about. Like, I think this is different
because American service members are dying and the violence seems
to be spreading and Iran seem seems to be forcing some kind of
an issue here, forcing some kind of a maybe ceasefire. I'm not
really sure what they're up to. Um, but I mean, just to be clear,
I do principally oppose like both of those strikes. Uh, like
I can be okay with I can I can be okay with an outcome, but
Iran, I think Iran
Honestly, it seems I feel like Iran is attempting
if I had to if I had to say what their what their hope is here,
they're hoping to take this global economic crisis and pin it
on Israel and turn all global political will against Israel,
right? That like, "Hey, we were ready to negotiate. Hey, we were
ready to like put our arms down and they decided they had they
had to have regime change and they had to [__] with
us, right? We were ready to negotiate through all of this and
might have been in bad faith, but you objectively during negotiations
struck them first, preemptively, okay?
So, when when we enter this next global economic crisis, right?
Everybody's going to point at Israel, justifiably so, in my opinion.
But still but still say that I don't think that it should have
happened that way or I don't think it should have
>> And you know, I'm trying to think of that even like
Yeah, I mean, like I mean,
>> had been indicted, which is like politically motivated,
like maybe you share this. I have a million and one reasons that
I hate Comey, but I would I wouldn't like rah-rah, like, "Yeah,
Comey's getting like held to account because the reason why in
this instance is because of like he's being politically targeted
and it's not it's a weaponization of the DOJ for them to be going
after him. So, even if like I could see like, "Oh, well, at least
there's like a silver lining to this." I don't just hesitate,
like I'm unwilling to grant that that's a positive because I
see these two things as like inextricably linked. Like, there
is no way to praise the outcome without in some way tacitly being
okay with the things that led to Well, sorry, but Aaron wins
on either side of this argument against Hutch because Hutch has
to take this position because this is precisely what he was against
with Rashad, right?
Like hey, I'm against fishing expeditions. Why are you against
fishing expeditions? Well, because, you know, even if you find
something it looks bad and and like it's it's wrong to do and
it's like, well, but what if they're actually corrupt and the
fishing expedition leads to you catching a fish? He's against
the fishing expeditions. That is like he basically loses on either
side of this if you know the examples. that outcome in the first
place. And I think it is disastrous to do this also because if
it's if we're going to give Trump or the GOP or anybody any semblance
of credit for like taking out the Ayatollah, I feel like that
makes America look weak. Cuz then to me all you're revealing
is that that's the type of military action you want to engage
in and you want to do, but you don't do it for some reason and
then you're going to applaud when somebody else like breaks the
law on your and like gets the outcome that you want that you
held yourself back from doing. Like no, I think it needs to be
made abundantly clear that this is not um something that people
should normalize like it is actually I mean, the poll that you
gave me is not good to hear that like a simple majority of even
like a simple majority of Americans are like the Iranian strikes.
But this is where I think that you should be like hammering it
on down like your first principles because there's a lot of things
you could pull the American public on that they would support
that are unconstitutional like wrong, unprincipled, would be
would maybe have some short-term benefits but would be long-term
destabilizing domestically or um internationally. And it's why
like I obviously put stock in American public opinion as far
as like trying to, you know, craft messaging or see where the
appetite is for certain policies and whatnot. But as far as like
the American public determining like what is and is not constitutional,
I think that people have just gotten way too used to thinking
that like, oh, this is business as usual because like
Does Erin actually care about Dems winning or is this just concern
trolling? Isn't she a communist?
I mean, just objectively on the face of it, Erin has almost certainly
done more to elect Democrats to the United States Congress than
anybody in Hutch's chat.
I'm sorry. I don't say that as it like I'm not That's just a
fact. She's done far more than most of these people. Like Congress
hasn't officially declared war since like World War literally
like decades and decades ago. But if we want to get back to these
norms like you do with like the DOJ not being weaponized, I think
we need to like look beyond um if it's viable in the short term
or if America you can get like a simple majority of Americans
to get on board with it and kind of get back to like emphasizing
and underscoring that like we do not want all of the power to
be concentrated in the executive and like reminding people that
that is not like what Trump is doing is not really like just
business as usual or just sort of like a like a little bit more
ambitious than like even what George Bush was doing. It's like
insane amounts of authoritarian grabs. And I also don't think
it's a coincidence that he does this after the Supreme Court
tells him, "No, you can't do the terrorist thing." That is also
a power that resides with Congress. It's like, "You can't just
do it." I felt like it was a show of force. I was like, "To save
you, like watch me take this unilateral action and there's not
really going to be there's like not going to be any dissent."
Nobody Nobody engaging with the single argument Aaron's making
at all. Um $20. I do not enjoy straight rate pretending to care
for democracy or its
I These people are so they're just beyond belief. >> party?
And there's only going to be um What's What's even more sad than
all of this is the people who are attacking Aaron for not caring
about democracy are the same people who worked with her in a
pack that cared about democracy.
You know what I'm saying? Like how do you work with this person?
You have conversations with her and she's clearly helping you
like win. And she's, by the in a in an administrative role, not
in a like influencer role where she could possibly get clout
from this, where she could possibly get like her platform like
like upped or boosted in any way. In a purely administrative
role. She's like answering emails and emailing people, right?
So, she wasn't even helping in a way that could help communism
or something in any way. She was just working in an administrative
role, right? And supporting like all their events, tweeting about
it, like willing to talk to the people who went to the events
and hang out and be a part of the whole movement, right? And
she went canvassing before that when she wasn't a part of PV.
It's like, "Dude,
how do you How do you guys all forget that? How do you all throw
that to the wind and then attack the same person?" Um like there's
not going to be total dissent from even the minority party. Um
I don't remember applauding um Trump in the in the second strike.
I think like the extent of my rhetoric on the first strike was
like I don't like that he did that. I'm Okay, next question.
By the way, highest paying job you ever had? Next question. If
you're not so erudite, you're in a high role in PV and you believe
Aaron is totally a liberal, not somebody who favors democracy,
why are you hiring a a total tankie, a a total communist who
hates democracy and wants the downfall of America
to work for your PAC? Super familiar with the constitutional
article >> arguments for why he can't or can't do that
as president. Um, but I'm not going to complain if if some of
their like nuclear developments got stalled for like 6 months
cuz I do think that I would rather live in a world where Iran
doesn't have a nuclear weapon, but I don't think I ever came
out and said like I think I I I like the way that that happened
or I think that that that should be a norm. And then as far as
the second strike goes, I definitely did not applaud that strike.
I said that >> Yeah, at the time that was something that
hadn't happened yet. Just the first one. Well, now I'm curious
about cuz I feel like when we spoke, you described yourself as
a communist, right? So, what is what is your what is your
Uh, so do you do you like the norms that exist currently in the
like American system of government? Uh, no. But, what I'm talking
about is not just like a a norm or whatever that we've like So,
yeah, this is what will happen at this point, right? It will
be people in chat making these arguments for him. He's going
to consistently look at chat, he's going to consistently be referencing
chat. He has no thought process of his own. He will just
read the chat.
That's what Hutch can do. Hutch, I'll be honest, if Food Chops
wasn't like so off-putting fundamentally as a human being, she's
probably on the same They're on the same intellectual level where
like they do the same thing. Where they have like totally They
don't have any core like system of beliefs. They kind of have
some things cobbled together from people who argue and and convince
them of stuff and then
they will basically take arguments from chat that contradict
each other. I'm positive Hutch will contradict himself at some
point in this whole argument. You know what I'm saying? I'm positive
he will because it's literally the same thing. Like when you
only take arguments from chat, when you don't have some like
overriding worldview or even just I like I don't have like a
I don't have like some, you know, principled philosophical basis
for all of my decision-making that I then apply from that first
principle out through the world, right? I have things that contradict
in the stuff I believe, but I'm smart enough to not contradict
myself in one conversation most of the time. Okay? But Hutch
no, Hutch no shot. observed or like just a tradition, it's actually
like the law that the executive not not undertake those actions
unilaterally without consulting Congress. Like in your system,
in your ideal system, what would be the checks against that kind
of unilateral military
Um I'm in it's hard to say. It's hard to imagine championing
anything other than a system at a national or like anywhere from
a municipal or national level that doesn't have significant separations
of power and checks and balances. I do think that I guess I on
certain things I diverge from progressives and I am more comfortable
with there being some I guess some sort of like
unitary power concentrated first to administer certain things,
but it has more to do with like wanting to not have so many be
two points that like erode that become self-defeating. Kind of
like honestly what Ezra Klein talks about like in abundance with
respect to housing. Like I don't agree with like the prescriptions
that he makes as far as like deregulating certain in certain
but the criticisms that he makes about the reason why we've gotten
to the housing crisis as far as criticizing the Why why are you
arguing about what Erin wants in like a hypothetical world that
she very much Like here's the thing, when when people want to
go to the communism thing with Erin or anyone else, all they
should say is I don't advocate for any of that stuff. I don't
think that stuff is coming in my lifetime. I think it's like
an ideal to push towards and I don't think it's happening right
now. So like we're we're just we're working towards that as an
ideal, but it's like an ideal it's like a North Star. I'm talking
about what I believe and about how the US government should work
right now. Why can't we have this conversation about how the
US government should work right now? And they're like, "Well,
you want to steal all private property." It's What? No, I don't
want to do that. Like I might think that private property leads
to certain bad effects in the world and ideally we could work
towards a world where there's less and less private property.
There's less and less distinction between the the wealth of human
beings.
But anyway, Cedars, I totally agree with that there does come
a point where are these vetoes are the all are all these different
veto points that we have actually like expanding or maximizing
like freedom or are they just like pointless red tape that's
actually impeding people's ability to get things done in our
government and like creating just administrative nightmares that
are very very expensive and actually harm people both short and
long term because they're not able to get access to the things
that they need. Um sorry, I don't know if that's a satisfying
answer or whatever. It's like hard to picture
term because they're not able
We got the faces coming out again, guys. I I stopped listening,
so I'm just going to make a face. That sounds kind of communist,
bro. That's how Well, everything you just said there, that sounds
kind of communist, bro. I don't know about I don't know about
communism, bro. Like you kind of want to do commie. You want
to do communism, bro. I don't know about that. I don't know about
>> able to get access to the things that they need. Um
sorry, I don't know if that's a satisfying answer or whatever.
It's like hard to picture these sort of like, you know, more
utopian visions or whatever. I'm I'm just mostly a forthcoming
with that because that is where I am like ideologically, but
given the fact that like It sounds like what you were saying
is that you're So, in your ideal system, would there be a singular
leader and then would that leader have a lot more authority than
the current president does?
She She just answered that. She just answered that. That on in
a military sense, she doesn't think that would be good in a domestic
or like in a in an economic sense, she thinks that could be good.
Right? Like that that was the gist of her what she said was like
in a military sense, I do believe, you know, everybody there
should be checks and balances. It shouldn't be cons- consolidated
power because obviously that could lead to just one person trying
to take over the planet or something, right?
So, so She He just did the thing that he did to Josiah. I'm not
going to listen to you. I'm going to make it obvious I didn't
listen to you. And again, I'm firmly of the belief now that he
does not have the
So, that's rough, but unfortunately he engages in an area where
that lack of capacity doesn't get him off the hook,
He's he's literally doing this professionally. So, I'm going
to judge him as if he does have the capacity because that's the
field he decided to go into as a professional, okay?
Kind of a nerd reference, but the original Marxists were social
democrats. All the Austro-Marxists believed in parliamentary
democracy including Engels. Oh, oh, interesting. Oh, >> lot
less like checks on their authority. No, I don't think there'd
be more in my >> in my ideal system. I think like the president
has to enjoys too much power currently. And then so like what
would be the mechanism? So, so would there be something resembling
a parliament or a congress and a judiciary or what? >> I
like closer to a parliament system because I don't like the two-party
duopoly and I do think that there is value in um like lower thresholds
for being able to accomplish things and coalitions that maybe
reach pluralities rather than majorities or supermajorities,
um but I do think that there is value in preserving um like constitutional
amendment changes of which like any vision of a society that
I see for like the next 100 years will have a would have a constitution
that everybody but Dude, and the funny thing is is not communism
then. Not communism then. Okay. citizens and politicians, public
servants, uh judges, etc. is bound to. Um we would not be like
super easy to um change the constitution or amend the >> And then
by what process would your system So, the funniest part of all
of this, right? The funniest part of all of this is like they've
just defined this is these people are the same as Fetterman or
Lindsey Graham in their souls, okay? I know that I have to hate
Stateraide. So, I'm going to come up with any reason I can to
hate Stateraide. We're going to make her define her entire worldview
from first principles all the way to the most detailed policies
and we will find some things to criticize along the way and so
I can hate Stateraide, right?
Hutch is literally instead of instead of talking about why he
supports or doesn't support these strikes Trump's done, he has
turned this into, "Yeah, but you like don't support democracy,
right?
It's become an interrogation of her beliefs instead of anything
he believes.
It's very sad. >> Um, appoint judges and positions in Parliament
and like the national leader, whatever you call that, a president
or prime minister. Like by what mechanism are do these are these
people put in those positions? Uh, no voting. It would be voting.
>> See, this is so I don't know. I feel like this is one
of the critiques of Marx that I've heard though is that you kind
of get at a system that very closely resembles liberal democracy.
You know, you can imagine a system where people are trying to
explore Yeah, she's like
I I do believe she doesn't want yeah, yeah, no you know, operate
like Marx's ideology into the government, but then with all the
bureaucracy and all these mechanisms you kind of end up just
like recreating liberalism. But how's this >> a there's
a difference between like to me a bureaucracy versus checks,
which is a delineation that I was trying to draw with like the
housing example. Like in my ideal world like housing is like
understood as a human right, not a commodity and it's guaranteed
and nationalized and there would be like sort of like a secretary
of housing in the same way that we have that for like secretary
of state, defense, transportation. There would be one for housing
and they would likely
be confirmed or appointed by some sort of executive. I just don't
like the consolidation of like I feel like our our president
right now is kind of like a prime minister, but the difference
is that they are like our constitutional like gridlock makes
it or like our congressional and political gridlock in some ways
like enables them too much and in other ways doesn't curtail
their ability to get things done enough and I think what you're
seeing with people's desire or at least kind of like not they
don't have forceful opposition to all of the power grabs that
Trump's making is that they are noticing that our system is really
not like it is meant to encourage compromise and for there to
be a consensus and it wants change to be very slow, but it makes
things so slow and it gets up and it interferes with president's
ability to get things done that you see more and more and more
presidents and start to use like executive action to get things
done cuz they can't really rely on Congress to do it and I'd
like to see like reforms made to our system or any future system
that I would be interested in. One where and this is why I like
the parliamentary system more, one where that we can like kind
of all acknowledge that like I don't think the founding fathers
or the framers of the Constitution ever envisioned that their
system would actually lead to there would be so much polarization
if the system would actually lead to um actors within the government,
especially when you have actors as bad as like the GOP, incentivized
to make power grabs and then entire squads of the population
like millions and millions of people uh gleefully okay with this
because they're sick of how much bureaucracy exists um to check
the president. She's literally just describing basically like
the slow fall towards populism and
right? That like hey, there's it's total gridlock, we can't come
to a consensus. That the way you get through like gridlock periods
is through somebody basically doing authoritarian power grabs.
There's like some sort of conflict that happens whether that's
armed or unarmed, right? And then you sort of eventually things
settle down and you go back to some sort of gridlocked system
again where things are But they're like they're casting away
things that are like and like that's not bureaucracy, people.
That is like again a check on power. And I think I agree with
this a little bit, Saify. I agree with this a little bit. Also,
Max, you're talking about Yeah, I do think this is this is the
tension that exists, right? With social democrats and and like
um the more communist types is like a Conor Boy has like a plan
for how you sort of slowly move towards some kind of socialism,
right? But realistically, I think a lot of people who are on
that side of the fence, who who will stay away from any sort
of revolutionary talk, they probably understand that they're
never going to get the system they ultimately want. They're like
trying to describe like an incremental path such that you can
start building towards that system, right?
But they're they're probably understanding that yeah, to eventually
you do have to get over whether or not you'll override popular
will.
That's like the differentiation the the delineation between Marxist-Leninists
and other people, right?
I think the conflation is being made in and uh Well, I guess
Marxist-Leninists is is more pushing the the heavy revolutionary
stuff, the the stuff like we're going to come up with a system
to force this to happen. So, maybe that's not the delineation.
That's uh but there there's something there. There's serious
delineation between these these couple of positions. I don't.
We don't like to see it, folks. I do wish that people could recognize
that like they're going to be changed without being like, "Yeah,
let's just enable the president to do whatever he wants so he
can get it done." Well, so you can have um guaranteed housing
within a liberal democracy and a capitalistic structure. So,
I still don't really understand like you're describing a system
that has a
It has democratically elected
Um that just sounds like a constitutional republic. So, So, where's
the communism part of this? Well, every single state, whether
they have a constitution that more Well, this would be this would
probably be in the organization of the economy, right? Right?
Huh? closely resembles ours or is even like authoritarian or
totalitarian in some way, shape, or form has what's understood
as like a constitutional framework even if it doesn't look exactly
like what we think. So, that is certainly not unique to a liberal
government. That is a feature of like any state apparatus that
has a constitution. No, but liberalism But, liberalism there's
like a These are These are hallmarks of liberalism though, these
like co-equal branches of government, checks on authority, you
know, constitutional rights, individual >> Yeah. You know,
so I don't even I mean like I don't like view that as a criticism
of Marx. Like I find that to be some ways like a feature and
in some ways like a reason why I think leftist should be more
interested in making building coalitions and inroads with different
political parties in this country and like certainly to value
like understand the value of these processes and like how they
are seeding a lot of power to interests that don't need to have
it when it could be there if we just be disciplined enough to
organize not just uh
>> Uh not so erudite interest to Chad. Not so erudite who
absolutely hates straight raid. I wonder what I wonder what side
she'll take, guys.
Person despises straight raid.
like locally or within like a community through related efforts
but also like get into the state and then exercise power. Sorry,
I don't want to lose the thread here. I just I I want to explore
how your system is meaningfully different from the current system.
Like why why the term communist? Because it's like so What? I
don't know uh Aaron, this is one of the things where it's like
this isn't the disagreement.
This isn't the disagreement at all. He should ask Aaron should
ask like are you willing to talk to me given I disagree with
you on the way the economy should be organized or are you not?
And if the answer is no, then we don't have to talk. But if it's
just going to turn into an interrogation of that, that's [__]
boring.
So far, what you're describing to me is, you know, the current
system with more >> Or set it up for a different conversation.
or democratic
kind of institutions. Like I would I would agree And she should
be forceful about this because otherwise, it's just going to
turn in a turn into a critique as of like her as a person and
her principles, which I've never even seen Hutch like his first
principles the way he thinks about the world. Like like from
a from a bedrock philosophical point of view outwards into like
how the economy is organized, how the government set up, all
of this stuff, right? Other than I just like the way it is, man.
I just like stuff. This is we're in the ideal system, man. We
have like a parliamentary structure while it's not perfect and
there are problems with multi-party system, it's probably more
democratic than the way that we do it. We have like an electoral
college and a first past the poll um first past the post um two-party
system and, you know, institutional norms like the filibuster.
You know, I I agree >> Like that would be gone. Like no
electoral college, no filibuster. I think the Senate's undemocratic.
I think there ought to be different ways for the Supreme Oh,
well they worked together. Hold on. But they worked together.
I can't highlight your message, but they worked together before
that, by the way.
Like I know you're saying that the whistleblower stream, but
maybe that is maybe it's all animosity from the whistleblower
stream. Maybe. Might be. >> like that not related to the
court be expanded. I actually think it should be That's where
Erudite's career started to like spiral a little bit, okay? Was
the whistleblower stream. I say that she's probably like bigger
than she's ever been, to be honest. >> Like there needs
to be more um like
As a creator. input from voters as to like which Supreme Court
judges make it onto the Supreme Court given how much power they
have over people's lives. Uh there would be ranked choice voting
instead of I I I PREDICTED THAT YOU WERE GOING TO GO THAT ROUTE,
CHAT, and I immediately I I I I caught you before you could even
go that route, okay? I caught you before you could even go that
route, so I won. >> of things, but like
>> and onto with Supreme Court given how much power they
Ask her about private property. Ask her about private property.
Dude. have over people's lives. Uh there would be ranked choice
voting instead of just like these sorts of things, but like I
mean if you want to say that these are like negatives or like
how can you call yourself a communist or whatever? Like I don't
view those to be negatives. Like I like uh negative things. Um
like maybe this maybe this criticism is what you've heard. It's
like I've heard some people say like Marxists or uh like leftists
are kind of like the true liberals in the sense that the uh way
that they understand power relations in the world and the prescriptions
that they have for society society will be the will be the thing
that helps enable fulfillment of the like my meant principles
better than liberal democracy will be able to. Um
I I Okay, I understand all that and but I'm I'm still struggling
with like what
When you describe your prescription here, it just it it sounds
like just like social democracy. I just don't I don't understand
why why you >> have the end goal of like the abolition
of private property?
Oh, so that's That is where you're going. Like ultimately at
the end of the day that's the Oh, I that's super funny. Erin
probably saw her name in the chat and just leaned into that right
away. That like the end goal is we don't have to worry about
material things. But you want that to be a part of your your
system By saying I'm a communist, yes. That's like that's I don't
think that's like a oh secret's out like she doesn't think private
property should be legal. It's like no, I'm making that very
clear by calling myself a communist. Like I'm going to depart
from liberals in very very substantive ways at some point. I
just think that as far as what's politically viable now given
the constraints that exist and the fact that I wouldn't support
um authoritarian measures to bring about um like I don't think
the ends would justify Hutch should be super receptive to this
by the way because this is Hutch's whole thing on why he would
vote for Epstein, right? This is Hutch's whole argument for why
it's okay for him to say he'd vote for Epstein. I have a hierarchy
of concerns. At number one in that hierarchy,
number one thing in that hierarchy is this. It is I think you
have to support liberal norms. I think you have to
like the democracy. You have to not want to overthrow the democracy.
You have to want to respect liberal norms. Do you want to continue
liberal democracy? If yes, then that's my first condition. For
straight rate, she says, "Well, actually, I'm very similar. I
don't want to overthrow the the democracy. I want to respect
democratic norms, right?"
Hutch should be so receptive to this way of thinking.
But he's not somehow. >> By no means. So, that's why I
don't cast like democracy to the side, so I'm not a revolutionary
or an accelerationist or um any of that. I don't think that um
yeah, I think consent of the governed is a an important thing
to pay attention to, and I would not be interested in like im-
imposing my will, my political will upon other people without
them being on board or like understanding it. And there's like
a lot of work to be done, but like if my ultimate end end goal
is a stateless, classless, moneyless society where private property
is abolished, I don't think that you could say that like I'm
very similar to liberals like whatsoever in those respects, and
that's like always what I'm pushing for. But I also recognize
that like yeah, practical constraints. This like capitalism is
like an ethical world order. Like I couldn't tell you exactly
when conditions would be more favorable for like another system
to overtake it, but what I could tell you is that I wouldn't
support authoritarian measures to bring about the end of capitalism,
if that makes sense. You think you could get there through reforms,
through gradual reforms, and and build a build a kind of democratic
consensus? Well, um Yeah, and there's other there's other like
leftist theorists that think this. Anybody who's like heard of
like Murray Bookchin, he like outlines this in like what he calls
like anarcho- >> Maybe maybe Hutch is there. Maybe Hutch
is there, okay? Maybe maybe >> This is like very very niche,
like getting into it. >> Well, I don't know if he would
call himself a communist, but um communist, but No, he's like
a socialist, right? Well, so when you say like no pri- Everyone
wants a utopia that literally can't exist. Yes, but her worldview
is understanding of that. Right? That's why she doesn't want
to overthrow the democracy. That's why she doesn't want to do
the revolution. Is it's like, "Okay, if we can't get there democratically,
I don't want it. But I want to I want to Think about I want to
move in that direction, right?" So, Hutch, I hope uh listen,
I've got a tweet cooking already.
All right? We'll see I'll show you I'll literally show it to
you, okay? Hutch, I'd vote for Epstein over anyone who doesn't
respect liberal democracy. Straight right. Ideally, we can abolish
private property, but I want to do this without overthrowing
the democracy. I respect liberal democracy. Hutch, let's see
what Hutch's response is cuz if it's if it's good, I don't have
to tweet it. But if it's if he's going to listen to his chat
Private property means like so the government would delegate
like what kind of house you live in, so is that what we're talking
about? They Well, no, no, no. Nationalization of an industry
is different than the abolition of private
So what does that mean? Like so if I say, you know, if you're
a family of five and you just decide one day you don't really
like the climate in the area that you live, how would you like
move? I mean, would you have just free movement to like I want
to go to Idaho and and and you just go to the government and
the government gives you a house or how does that work? Yeah,
largely the same system. It's not a question of changing those
mechanisms. It's just a question of who is going to own it.
And right now I think it should be guaranteed because the issue
to me with housing and like a big reason why we have the housing
shortage is because for housing to more housing to be made, it
needs to be the best investment that capitalists can make as
opposed to any other investment that they could put their money
into. But the need for housing is inelastic. It is a basic need
that we all require in the same way we need health care, we need
dental access to like dental hygiene, we need water, we need
oh wait, clean water specifically, we need electricity. Like
housing is like a non-negotiable. And so ideally in the wealthiest
state country in the in the whole world, this could be something
that is like guaranteed by the >> And you would still have
possessions, right? Like you would still be able to like own
things like a TV or a you know, like a video game console or
>> personal property. Marx makes a distinction between
this. Private property is like productive assets that rely on
the exploitation of labor to
like make profits. But personal property like your toothbrush,
like your computer or whatever, that would never be state I hate
Well, he's not he's literally not How does Hutch have no mods?
No, he has lots of mods. The mods just all hate Straight Right.
The mods just all hate Straight Right. Okay. And That's just
personal property. Okay, so let's say well and then okay, so
then I ostensibly there would be some kind of a police system,
right? So like if somebody stole a TV that you would be able
to like call police and get some kind of state remedy to
Like does he does he engage
What? You asked this Why did you ask that question? If you have
no further commentary, why did you ask about the housing Why
did you ask? Why were you digging down on that at all? If you're
just going to switch I don't like the way that's that's that
sounds like a good argument. I don't have anything to say to
that. Okay, but you would have like police, right? Like you would
have like police in your state, like state police, like you'd
have a police state. >> right? Or Yes, there would be laws.
Well, like there's there's like also two different distinctions
that Marx makes. There's like lower level communism and then
there's higher level of not like full communism. And this is
what later came to be understood as like the distinction between
socialism and
by Lenin cuz he expanded upon Marx's work. But Marx himself used
socialism and communism largely interchangeably. They just referred
to like kind of like different stages of it. Um and [clears throat]
in the meantime, there is a necessity to maintain state apparatuses
just to facilitate
people having access to the goods that they
resource resource distribution and whatnot. Like it would be
a terrible terrible By the way, I think isn't she talking about
like
I maybe I missed this. Isn't she talking about like why housing
should be subsidized by the government right now? I I didn't
think this was about maybe I missed the part >> would be
like Russia if you tried to do if you tried to like have like
really really bad like free market reforms where like you can
consolidate you can see like consolidations of capital very very
quickly, which is how like they result they got like an oligarchy
or whatever. Like accelerating and like forcing the dismantlement
of these things or enforce like trying to force reforms when
the conditions and stuff like the developing conditions of a
country like are not ready for that. Like you will lead it will
lead to a disaster, which is why I like um like electoral reforms
and like some gradualism. Well, Marx talked about the necessity
for there to be like a period of industrialization where capitalism
would just roared for a while and Lenin came in and he kind of
he kind of injected a new kind of theory, which is that you can
jump straight to the to the socialism but while they were while
they were like aggressively industrializing, but you know, like
so in your system like if
it's it's again it's this basic critique that I've had the whole
time that Hutch cannot listen to another person, understand what
they're saying, and then integrate that into his conversation.
Like basically like Aaron just makes a bunch of arguments there.
She she basically is explaining why the gradualism is important
to her, right? And he goes, "Yeah, like Lenin basically said
that you can
while socialism."
Okay. I He's like incapable of like having conversations with
Hutch may actually be
Like I'm not sure he's understood or or really reacted to outside
of the chat reacting to her, right? Like that's how he fains
it is is the chat will react to what she's saying. So sometimes
he can read the chat and the chat will understand what she's
saying. But for him, I think he's almost entirely incapable.
If you want a new TV, like what does that look like? If there's
no currency, do you just like go to the Best Buy and just take
it off the shelf and that's it or how does that how does that
work?
IS SOMEBODY JUST TYPING TO him or
Is like I don't know bro, I'm sorry.
Um you have to go to like meta conversation. If Mr. Girl was
watching this, he would lose his mind and have to like you have
to go to a meta conversation here, right? Hey, have you noticed
that he's like giving you responses here? The same thing that
happened to Josiah is happening to Aaron right now.
Right? You have to go to a meta conversation
and say, "Have you noticed how you're not responding? You asked
me a question and I respond and then you just ask a completely
distinct
Like repeatedly. That's repeated that's the process we keep going
through.
It's hard to say because you're asking me to like talk about
the specifics of like a post-scarcity society where not only
are resources um abundant within society as it is. It's like
a matter of like making sure that there's distribution. Like
I like uh I feel like I'll give you I'll give you like unsatisfying
answers because there is a reason a lot of it remains theoretical
because trying to make these sorts of more like concrete prescriptions
of how to like how those more specific things are going to work
um once like communism is achieved, which again is like literally
I would assume like literally thousands of years off in this
like post like like Star Trek ask utopia. Okay. So, literally
as any intelligent person could tell you could could inform you
like sorry any intelligence communist intelligent communist would
think this that like
then trying to necessitate the revolution happening now like
trying to get communist communism in my lifetime would require
violent revolution. She's ruled it out in her lifetime. She doesn't
know exactly how it'll be accomplished. She's saying ideally
we don't have private property
philosophically private property leads to these things these
problems. The the basic premises aren't really
Like the basic premises are true. It's really about you should
be arguing that you can't do this in like a a small time Right?
That's the arguments against communism. It's not that it's philosophically
wrong or philosophically bad. It's that the prescriptions the
the idea of what you would do to get there from now are almost
unknowable and it's like well this ethos this animating ethos
is something like I want to take care of people. I don't want
people to be struggling to get along in life. In the richest
country in the world we shouldn't be struggling to get along
in
It's like come on. We're not even saying crazy things. We're
just saying obvious things. Um I can really only tell you like
what I wouldn't be okay with as opposed to what I would. You
know what I mean? Sure, but so like are there markets in your
in in this communism? Are there is markets are those even a thing?
Mar Yeah, there's always markets. Okay.
Like whether the state recognizes it or not market market exists.
They can exist outside of like formal structures.
So, I mean, it just So, so are you talking about a a totally
centrally planned economy or are you talking about like a combination
of like you know, mark I've I've finished the Hutch tweet, okay?
The Hutch tweet is finished.
Here's the Hutch tweet, okay? It is now
Hutch, I'd vote for Epstein over anyone who doesn't respect liberal
democracy. Shrewd, ideally we can abolish abolish property, but
I want to do this without overthrowing the the democracy. I respect
liberal democracy. Hutch, but how do you buy a TV in communism?
That's That's like where the conversation's at, right? That's
about what it is. I think so.
I think so.
That's That's about what the conversation was so far. Market
socialism and and and and like what are So, what does that look
like? Yeah. If it's not all centrally planned >> market
socialism would be ideal where you slowly begin to decommodify
workplaces and people have more of a say over the area of their
life where they spend I mean, most people spend like from the
age of like even slightly before 18 all the way up until they're
like in their 50s, 60s working and are even though we like emphasize
and underscore the importance of democracy outside of the workplace.
Uh, market socialism is to the fact that it is not It is important
to not disregard the fact that uh, like when you're like 8 hours
a day functionally just so you can live, you are under the boot
of your boss that makes largely like unilateral decisions over
what you will do for like a good portion of your life and expanding
democracy to the workplace is like some of the like best, easiest,
and most tangible ways in the short term you could start to bring
about um, like abolishing wage slavery entirely, uh, abolishing
private property, and expanding democracy. What does that mean
to abolish wage wage slavery? What does that mean?
Uh, how do I put this into words? So, like we technically have
a choice to work, right? By the way, Aaron has totally conceded
that like all of these conversations they're having like a hypothetical
principled uh, philosophical conversation. She's conceded none
of this is happening right away. It's like not happening right
Right? She's openly conceded this
So, why is this relevant to the other conversation about how
he reacted to Rashad? Aaron, if you're here, if you're listening,
I don't know if you're actually listening, but if you're listening,
for the love of God, please
this might be maybe this would just be bad for you or something.
I don't know. But please don't let people like run you in circles
like this. Don't If they want to have a conversation about communism,
say we can have that conversation another time. I If I If I watch
you argue about communism again on a stream, I'm going to shoot
myself in the head, okay? So, know that that will be on you.
Just know that that will be on you.
Okay? Have the conversation you came here to have, or don't have
a conversation. But it's like actually just total garbage. She
came here to argue with Hutch about his beliefs about some of
the stuff he's been saying, and then instead of that, you're
just talking about communism when he already knew you're a communist.
Okay? And by the way, yeah, you're not necessarily arguing badly.
I don't care about the argument or how good you're arguing against
him, or how well you're explaining your beliefs. I'm just saying
that it's like it's I can't I can't do that without being accused
of running. Just say I'm perfectly happy. We can schedule it
right now. We'll have that whole conversation. I'm perfectly
happy to do it. Right?
I'm perfectly happy to have that conversation with you. But I'm
going to have that conversation with you at a different time.
If you can't talk to me until we have that conversation, then
I don't think you are actually looking for any critiques. I don't
think you're willing to engage with criticism of you. I think
you are running from it. Um Like in this like you don't you don't
get like a criminal penalty if you don't get a job, correct?
Sure. Sure. Sure. Yeah. Right. But what But what happens if you
don't get a job?
You probably end up homeless, or if you're if you're lucky, maybe
you have a family member that you can mooch off of, and you know,
yeah. Correct. But like that and like that family member is probably
a wage slave. That family member probably works so you can do
that, and then you're just like, yeah, siphoning off like money
from somebody else. Right now, the the option is do the thing,
and the thing being work work for like 8 hours a day, whatever
it is, or live a subsistence existence at best if you can find
a way to like, you know, coast off of some like government programs
or basically abject poverty and >> What what happens to
>> So, it's not really like a meaningful choice, right?
You like you have to work. Well, I mean, I assume people would
have to work in your system, too, right? Yes, they would, but
this would not be coerced through poverty or The crazy thing
is, I I just don't I literally don't understand.
This is Honestly, Aaron, this is why you should just say you're
like a liberal. Like you're functionally a liberal. It's
Like it's so worthless to have this this whole talk. It's not
something Hutch even cares about. Also, he's not even listening
to begin with. But it's like I'm not I'm not going to say anything.
I'll let it go. Well, like how? Like let's say somebody in your
system decide, "I don't really want to work for like the rest
of my life." Like how how would you incentivize that person to
contribute to society?
Uh well, to to I'm going to break this into two parts. For one,
every single system, even right now, there are always people
that opt not to work. Even with how bad it is, like how poor
and awful your life will be if you do not work, because again,
you'll be subjecting yourself to like homelessness, you'll live
in a very precarious situation, um opening yourself up to like,
you know, substance abuse, like the likely the likelihoods for
all of these things, disease, like there's tons of reasons When
will the J dog Hutch debate happen? Hutch is running. Hutch will
continue
Hutch will run. By the way, I don't even know that like I don't
have something I've super wanted to debate Hutch on. I've like
he if he wants to lay out or if he wants to watch any of my videos
and disagrees with something I've said, I'd be perfectly happy
to argue with I'm perfect I'm happy right now. I I would talk
to him now just because he basically tried to rule that out
But there are multiple things. Like yeah, Queenie was the person
who wanted to talk to him. I'd find something to argue with him
about. I could. I know I I disagree with him on a lot of stuff.
I just off the top of my head, it's like I've never been like,
"No, you have to talk to me."
Now Now I want to talk to him just cuz he seems to have like
decided that I'm evil, which I don't even understand. Straight
rage far more evil than I am. She believes in communism.
This is why you shouldn't like there will always be people that
like opt to do this. Um and I think in the same way right now
our system has built in mechanism >> Sorry, that opt not
to work or to I'm sorry, I lost you. >> that opt not to
work. Even though it like doesn't make It's not safe for people
really to like not have a job and have secure employment because
that's the thing that enables you to have um shelter, food, water,
electricity, all of these things like reliably. Um and then so
like no matter it seems like no matter what system even under
capitalism, there will always exist a contingent of the population
that will just kind of be like moochers, right? But I think that
this is like largely Honestly, and this is probably like maybe
the most fantastical that I'll sound in this conversation. I
think people enjoy working and people enjoy laboring and to the
extent that you saw as like this this like bum class, um I don't
think it would be substantially larger than like to the extent
that that basically exists now or in other
>> I don't know cuz I mean I I understand what you mean.
I think that human beings crave like a creative outlet and um
I think human beings should have dignity. Yeah? Do you know how
to get us there in the current democracy?
Yeah? You think human should have dignity? Oh, okay. Well, guess
what? Unless you can tell me how to get human human beings dignity
tomorrow, your worldview is irrelevant.
What the [__] are you saying? I Do we understand
how stupid this is?
We understand how stupid this is, right?
that you can't express some ideal for the world without having
a plan to get there immediately?
And listen, if Erin was going live every day on her stream and
was saying "Co- communism Communism is the only way. Communism
Communism now. Communism's the only way. We need a revolution.
Communism." But she literally goes live and she is functionally
a liberal
Okay? A leftist pundit, we'll say. A leftist pundit.
She just reacts to content. She gives her opinion. None of it
is like anything to do with communism outside of some ideal like
some some first principle sort of giving her a north star.
Right? Um they do crave a sense of accomplishment and but if
you put me in a system where there was like no disincentive to
not working, I would probably think about maybe just not working.
No way. I mean like I think I think about this. Think about this.
I think there would be a lot of people who would be like, "Well,
I don't know if I want to do that. Why not? I'd rather sleep
in." or whatever. No, no, wait. I I I acknowledge there will
be lots of people. I'm just saying it's not a unique feature
to communism like people seem to think it is. It It's just a
unique thing to like kind of human or like a thing that humanity
is going to produce. Like there will always be this sort of class
of people that like, yeah, they don't really care. They don't
have prospects. But when we look the my strongest rebuttal against
this narrative is think about the types of societies like, you
know, fellow socialists and communists want to move towards.
Like like A Condoboy, right? A Condoboy would probably frequently
talk to you guys on Live and Learn about like the Nordic model,
right? And what happens in Scandinavia and Denmark or like the
housing programs in Vienna like these sorts of things, right?
Like where they have more robust welfare systems and yet nonetheless
their populations are happier, they have lower rates of poverty,
they have more productivity, and everybody Those are so I mean,
that's the difference between a welfare state and, you know,
you can't just get away with like not working in Norway. I mean,
there's there's their their their welfare state is like just
much more robust, but that doesn't mean that people are like,
"Ah, I think I'm just not going to work." Ah, yes. You just made
my point. That is literally what I'm saying is that you can have
these sorts of robust welfare states and it you don't actually
see a significant increase in people being like, "I'm just going
to take advantage of it." you know. Okay, I thought this conversation
so fighting straight raids and Lycan. Was this conversation not
supposed to be about the whole like, "Oh, you spend a lot of
time fighting like Pysonich?"
Is that not what the conversation was supposed to be about? How
did it turn into like a communism
My but my point was that there's limits to these welfare states.
Like if if someone in Sweden just decided they're not going to
work, I don't think that they would I I I don't know. You tell
me about the Swedish welfare system, but I doubt that they have
a system where they're just going to fully fund and subsidize
people who are able-bodied but choose not to work. I mean, like
a different a different problem that I would like pose to you
is, you know, let's say you're the head of state and you're working
with the parliament, and you come up with this really like ambitious
infrastructure plan, you know, you want to switch the entire
country to renewable energy, and you want to do high-speed rails,
whatever. Like, how do you incentivize people to actually do
the labor to build the infrastructure?
Without it being wildly authoritarian.
There's I have to challenge like a fundamental assumption like
like there's like a a premise that I think is implicit in a lot
of what you're asking me, which is that like communists believe
that there will be no labor in under communism, but that's not
true. What communists want to do is change the relationship that
exists between the laborer and their own work. And rather than
have it consolidated in the hands of capitalists that they own
the means of production and they own the means of their labor.
No, I understand all that. No, I understand all that, but there's
going to be some type of some some types of labor that are going
to be like much less desirable labor. Like some people
>> Hold on, let me go back. Wait, wait, wait, wait. Was
somebody like making that argument in in the chat that Hutch
just read and didn't come up with on his own? high-speed rails,
whatever. Like, how do you incentivize people to actually do
the labor to build the
>> who is totally like
Did I go back far enough? She Aerodite's arguing, "Well, who
does the bad jobs? Who does the jobs nobody wants?" She's arguing
that in the chat the whole time. Like ambitious speed rails,
whatever. Like, how do you incentivize people to actually do
the Uh it's there. It's there. Did I not I didn't highlight it.
It's there.
If anybody took a screenshot of this, if anybody was commenting,
cuz I know sometimes people will take the Aerodite screenshots
from chat and send them around, but it's literally just him,
once again, losing the conversation and relying on his chat to
make the arguments for him.
the labor to build the infrastructure.
Without it being wildly authoritarian.
There's I have to challenge like a fundamental assumption that
like like there's like a a premise that I think is implicit in
a lot of what you're asking me, which is that like communists
believe that there will be no labor in under communism, but that's
not true. What communists want to do is change the relationship
that exists between the laborer and their own work. And rather
than have it consolidated in the hands of capitalists that they
own the means of production and they own the means of their labor.
No, I understand all that, but there's going to be some type
of some some types of labor that are going to be like much less
desirable labor. Like some people are going to be much much more
You're going to have some people that have like more cushy jobs,
more you know, easier jobs, more creatively rewarding jobs. And
then you're going to have I mean like how does this automation
play into this? I mean maybe that solves your problem. Maybe
it's just the robots doing all this and like Um partially, partially
not. Like I do think that there's a reason why like the the kind
of easiest thing that I can vaguely gesture to to show that like
communists don't think it's like only going like oh, we can just
like let robots do all of that is like you probably see a lot
of like skepticism of AI come specifically from the left and
not liberals, right? >> Yeah, probably
I would generally agree with that. Yeah. Yeah, and so I I think
if communists and I share I share those criticisms as well just
thought like oh, it could be as simple as like the robots are
going to do everything for us, man. They would be like the biggest
advocates and champions of AI. Well, I do think that largely
like I I would love to for all of those things to be automated.
Like that to me is like a redeeming feature of AI is like the
prospect of that being the case where we don't have to have people
putting themselves in precarious uh like workplace conditions
to be able to um like help keep society running. Like and then
we could just have machinery doing it, but the I think a lot
of the skepticism comes from the fact that like there are so
many
The reason people do those jobs to begin with is cuz they're
paid a lot because the resources they're extracting are extremely
valuable. I would imagine in some sort of socialist society,
you would actually get allocated far more money, far more of
the profits of that like industry, right? The jobs would become
even more high-paying.
Right? Because they're a risk. Wouldn't that just be Isn't that
just a natural thing that would happen?
Bro, I don't even I don't even believe in this. It's like so
obvious some of these answers are just so obvious. Like if you
think about them for 2 seconds. >> the short-term issues
with the ethics of like expanding AI without reg The hardest
So, you're talking about like like people who are like ditch
diggers and stuff. I would imagine those jobs get some amount
of money, and if you don't have any other talents, any other
training, you do those jobs if you need to, right? Like I I don't
know. >> regulation um that there are like so many externalities
that it's important to not just cast those aside in the hopes
and promise of like the future utopia. Sorry, the the one that
Erin I brought up in the chat, so I assumed Hutch was referring
to that was um working on an oil rig.
Like high risk, like working on an oil rig, doing underwater
like um welding and stuff. Those are like for oil rigs as well.
That's like all very high-value industries, but if she's just
talking about like who's cleaning toilets, yeah, I assume that's
a problem under communism. Who's cleaning toilets? be an innovator.
I think it's also kind of [laughter] another thing I could like
Who cares about labor displacement if there's no The fact the
fact of the matter is is that under communism
you almost certainly would not have People think of communism
is like we just let people not work. Yeah, I don't think that
can happen under any communist model. Sorry. Pretty pretty confident
that that couldn't be allowed to happen. That they found a way
probably gulags in Russia to make people want to clean toilets,
okay? Hey, you don't want to clean the toilets? Guess
Do you want TO GO TO SIBERIA? NO? Then clean the [__]
toilets. There's no disincentive to not working. Like if the
robots replace you, but there's no penalty Yes, there's there
would have to be disincentives to not working. There would have
to be, right? Unless you're talking about future communism, like
space communism, in which case what are we even talking about?
There's space communism. People are not working, who gives a
[__] That's like vacation, party it party it up,
go nuts, right? Because the uh But also by the way that would
just be some place that would just be some obvious place where
you peel back, you go to Erin's first principle, I don't want
to overthrow democracy. I don't want to force people at the point
of a gun to do
Like I don't want to have to voice force you at the point of
a gun to clean a toilet. So, I guess we're not all the way to
communism yet, right? First principle is re- do not use authoritarian
overreach to force people to do like small things. Like don't
don't it be in the place where it's like you're going to the
gulag unless you listen to me. Right? That's like the first principle.
Well, not party it up go nuts because again there's other things
that need to happen for like society society to function. I just
think that liberals kind of downplay or don't acknowledge the
extent to which people are incentivized to do things other than
financial incentives. But do you disagree with this? >> Do
I disagree that people have other incentives besides financial
incentives?
Like to work or to innovate. I know people want to feel rewarded
in the things that they do for sure. Yeah, but >> Yeah, like
there's social there's like social incentives, there's reputational
incentives, there's like communal incentives and reasons to
to to work and labor. Like when you were saying like people are
just like going to not work. It's like this all already like
presupposes a society where people like don't want to like have
families. But if you don't have families and like like if you
want to like not work that badly, okay, but like you're there's
like so many social disincentives to that because you're never
you're like so difficult to find a partner when you're unemployed.
It's so difficult to find a No drive to do anything. Yeah, but
not in your system. Who cares? There's no if there's >> Not
who cares because again people like both men and women like if
they if they want to if they're so prioritized over like not
working that it like gets in the way of them having like a family.
I I just don't see this. Like the the entire point of economic
freedom is like to enable people to do these things.
Uh you know
With Aerodite in the chat, I just wish
I wish
there's no way to go back and make it
Could you imagine? Could you imagine if if Aaron just said
Hutch, how do you solve Agrippa's
Hutch, how do you solve Agrippa's Trilemma? How do you solve
You're you're you're like consistently asking me questions. You
just continue to ask me questions, ask me questions, ask me questions.
We'll never get to a solution here, right? How do you solve Agrippa's
Trilemma? How >> bouncing to a different kind of thing.
Like how do you solve the problem of like supply? You know, so
if is there currency? So there's no currency in your system or
is there? No currency. No, no currency ideally. No. All right.
So let's say you decide I want a 80-in TV in every single room.
And you you know, like and then a bunch of other people have
the same thought. And then there's just a permanent TV shortage.
Would you ration these kinds of things?
Um it's hard for me to contend with this cuz you're you're you're
getting into distribution of things that would be considered
like luxury goods, even if they're not like >> Is the United
Federation of Planets communist, objectively?
Wait, yes, it is, right? Isn't it I thought that was explicitly
a thing in Star Trek that they they literally do communism, don't
they? Like luxuries or whatever. Well, you're going to have luxury
items in your system, right? There will be luxury items, yes.
All right. And under gay automated like communism, it is going
to be luxury communism. I don't think I don't want people to
get the impression that communism is like a poverty culture that
I'm here to be like, "You don't need a Nintendo Switch. You don't
need like to be able to game." Or I'm like I'm not here for for
any of that. Like again, the entire point of me like being in
favor of this is because I think it enables people to like actually
spend time to like creative endeavors, and I don't want to see
those things go away. Well, how do you know I'll argue to you
that like we don't have like we actually don't have an abundance
issue. We have like a distribution issue. Because we actually
have abundance of a lot of things that people need. There are
right now lots of There are actually areas where there are empty
houses waiting for people to occupy them, but because and simultaneously
there's people that are completely that are homeless in our country.
So right now the issue is not that like we don't have or like
food. Like have you ever heard these stats where like
No, we have a NIMBY policy issue. Yes.
That's what she's saying. That's what she's describing.
That's that's like a literally a a huge fact or a huge portion
of what she's describing. It's not the entire thing. Sorry, I'm
I'm I'm looking at the chat
He's not listening. Do we see his eyes flick away again? As soon
as As soon as his eyes flick to the chat, he stopped listening
and he will have to go back to the chat for an argument, okay?
>> Like and in I swear we could go back through this whole
debate and we could just watch Hutch's eyes. And when his eyes
flicker over to the chat, he's stopped paying attention. And
then you're going to see them flick to the chat a second time
where he will look for the comment he wants to make in response
to what Aaron is saying, but he'll wait for her to stop talk
or stop talking. Because he hasn't listened, so he doesn't really
want to cut in. Right? entire like massive stadiums worth of
fresh food that could be filled from the bottom all the way to
the top of the stadium is thrown away every single day in this
country alone. >> a lot of food waste, yeah, for sure.
Good Yeah, like and and that's all happening under under communism
under capitalism where we're supposed to have more efficient
more efficiency. Not with there's not only with respect to to
maximizing profit margins, but also with distribution. And yet
you still see these market failures. You still see
you still see things just like going to waste and being thrown
away even though they're perfectly good. And so what we need
to do is like have a system that enables us not only to produce
that much, but like ask yourself like do we Well, it's it's really
funny and I do think the tweet actually highlights it
Right? It's like, "Hey, um first principle, I do respect liberal
democracy. I don't want to overthrow the democracy. So if something
is not working, if I can't make the thing happen, then I will
accept not being able to make the thing happen and look for new
solutions rather than overthrow the democracy, right?"
And then it's just another question about communism.
Yeah, this is the whole conversation. This is the loop of the
conversation.
Every single time.
Do we need to Do we need to produce that much? And if we do,
how do we make sure that it's distributed perfectly? And this
is where Marx came up with the mantra of like from each according
to one's ability to each according to one's need, which is how
you understand like who needs what in society. But if you're
going to have um a communist communist state with an abundance
of luxury goods, how do you regulate the supply of this without
some kind of a currency? Cuz like what again, like what is to
stop someone from saying, "I want an 80-in TV in every single
one of my rooms." And you know, like these these shelves The
same thing that stops people from doing it in this system now.
Wait, that's not true. I mean this is the the thing that stops
people from doing Find Find If you find me the guy who's like
obsessed with not only like what like like scalping
Dude, I
Um Aaron, by the way, I maybe you just didn't watch enough of
my content. Maybe, maybe.
At some point you do have to call out that Hutch is not responding
to the things you're saying. Like at some point you do have to
say, "I just said So you said this." This is how Josiah totally
ripped him, by the way. I said this, you said that. I said this,
you said something that was irrelevant to the points I just made.
You are not listening to me. Why aren't you listening to me?
Do you have no respect for me, or what is going on here, right?
That's the only way to talk to Hutch, because if you do not point
that out to Hutch, he will keep doing it. Hey, you're clearly
not when I You asked me a question, right? You asked me a question.
No, no, no, no, no, I'm not answering it. No, no, no, I'm not
answering it. Because he has to be embarrassed in front of his
chat repeatedly, so he starts listening. There is no other way,
okay? If he won't stop doing this thing to everybody he talks
to, he needs to be embarrassed until he either figures it out
or drops out of streaming.
He literally isn't capable of listening. Josiah got No, it's
not about the It's not about It's It's about making a point that
could be defended by anybody else,
When Josiah did it, it was perfect, because he literally said,
"You had this criticism. You said this thing. I came in, I was
a little heated. Then you said, well, what You know, can you
give me an example?" I gave you an
And then you continued to say I was super online. You didn't
engage with what I said, so now I'm upset. Right? He just ran
him through the whole conversation from start to finish to explain,
and that's what you have to do with Hutch. Actually, the previous
conversation he had with Aaron was another example of this. He
does this quite often, especially And the weird thing is is sometimes
when he agrees with people, you get some hint that he can do
it, but I don't know if that's just cuz he's watched a lot of
content, and he sort of knows the talking points. That's more
what I think is cuz when he talks to somebody he doesn't know
very well, or just talks about stuff he doesn't know very well,
he tends to do this thing, the same thing, where he's not paying
attention. being reselling TVs, but then also like they also
just like want to keep them so they can have a TV or whatever,
I will eat my hat. I will I will come on your stream, I will
turn on my camera, and eat my hat. I promise you. Well, I mean,
the the thing the thing that is a bullwark against that in the
current system is that resources are finite people you know most
people are not made of of money you know like you can't it's
expensive to put a 80 inch TV in every single room. That's pretty
strong disincentive to not like blow a bunch of cash. But if
you gave me a system >> Do you think there was no money
people would like get would want the like the like TV in every
room including the bathroom? Absolutely. I don't think so. No.
I would 1000% would want a 80 inch TV in every room if they were
free. >> Well if you okay this is all just projection and
this is you telling me about your like TV plans and this probably
isn't how you intend to to take advantage of the system then
uh sure. Sure well I I I I don't even
I I have like a big TV in most of my rooms. So I don't know.
I have a like a big TV in a couple of my rooms but the bathroom?
Putting a 80 inch TV in the >> I'll have to think harder
on that one on how to prevent um Hutch from getting a TV in every
single room in his house. >> Well you you'd come up with
like a currency. And then you would have like you know a market
solution to these kinds of to these kinds of problems. But your
system I mean you you surely you would have to ration things
right? Like everybody gets a coupon for one TV or something like
that.
Oh. I mean I would be opposed to that. Uh like as opposed to
like the system that we have now but I would have to I like I
don't really have a satisfying answer to something that I'd have
to think about more cuz to the extent that >> Well you
would have to think about these supply chains. I mean we saw
what happened after COVID. I mean like the the the the inflation
that we This is
It is unironically um It's funny that Erodites so supportive
of this way of arguing which he's not on the other side of it.
This is I believe the reason she pulled out the Agrippa's trilemma
thing is I think she thought Andrew Wilson was being like needlessly
focused on something that was irrelevant to the convo. Right?
The conversation is supposed to be why do you consistently cover
Hasan? Why are you doing this
And now this is totally irrelevant to the conversation. Right?
Or if it's not irrelevant to the conversation if you want to
say well if you're a communist then I don't want to talk to you
then just say that.
Cuz she's openly talked about the fact that she's a communist.
What we also happened after COVID was because these supply chains
were just so unbelievably overwhelmed. And then your system And
all under capitalism.
Right, but I mean All of that failure under capitalism. Well,
I mean, but you know, but I think your under your system where
everything was there's no currency and there's no limit to the
luxury items that you can own, the the problem that Um by the
way, if you want to if you want to preview of all of the what
do you call it? If you want to preview of all the base liberal
streamers who hate commies, you want the a preview of all of
their reactions when Erin goes like, "Oh, that all happened under
capitalism." Every single one of them is going to like pound
the table go, "Whoa, YOU YOU CAN'T EVEN DESCRIBE YOUR SYSTEM.
CAPITALISM WORKS. WHY YOU WHY YOU TAKING ONE FAILURE AND SAY"
They'll all lose their minds right there, okay? That's where
they'll all lose their minds. I think that was um that was like
kind of a cop out or whatever. But people will that'll be the
You want to know where the highlight reel's going to be? People
are going to cut clips out of it. Be right there, okay? I mean,
based after COVID under capitalism would have been like literally
a hundred times worse under your system. I don't know how I mean,
you would have you would have to have like
like three-fourths of the planet would have to be like manufacturing
infrastructure to accommodate the the system that you're Wait.
I can't wait until we Nothing. Nothing. Never mind. I have a
hard time I mean, like
You want to like America I just I feel like um there are failures
in every system.
There are failures in every system.
The real failure of We're about to watch the real failure of
capitalism possibly. Possibly. Not like the total failure, but
like when you watch what happens with this energy crisis, I feel
like we're going to see that like, oh,
maybe infinite expansion with the assumption that the system's
going to keep running totally normally is scary. A little bit
scary. Something that should be controlled for a little bit.
America is a You would agree that America is like a culture of
like hyper-consumerism, right? Oh, yeah. And a lot of that is
is fueled by, you know, cultural pressure and FOMO and just,
you know, a lot of technology that's happening these days just
being really cool and um >> There's three people
>> Uh so true, actually, Gummy Bear. Thank you. Yes. This
is I didn't consider this. Yes. Our best example is what is occurring
what is unfolding in front of
>> Well, plunging them plunging themselves into debt over
these consumer goods. Yeah. There's people that are financing
pizzas. They're using Klarna and Affirm or whatever to like pay
in four for like like DoorDash and they're Yeah, there's people
doing that like like now.
No, but don't you understand that we just need to regulate against
that? Actually like you're not you're not advocating for capitalism.
You're not pointing out a bad thing in capitalism. That's unregulated
capitalism. We hate unregulated capitalism, okay? We just need
regulation. >> No one ever made the claim Well, I certainly
I never made the claim that like Oh, no, no. I'm about to make
the
I'm about to make the claim that I think capitalism and a lot
of advertising, which like goes is under regulated to me. Like
advertising is something that I do think should be more tightly
regulated. Um these are to me like the excesses and like the
distractions that people engage in to make their lives fulfilling
because they undergo another thing that Marx describes as alienation.
People feel alienated from the product of their labor because
of the way that we people are like relate to their labor in the
first place and because of because of the wage slave system.
And you know, capitalists like selling you like encouraging you
to work for the majority of your life for a paltry existence
and living. And then oh, but you can make yourself happy like
by buying stuff even though people know that like stuff doesn't
really make people that happy or there's definitely
there's definitely limits to the happiness that consumer goods
can provide you. And yeah, I don't see that there being a movement
towards communism that doesn't start to sort of deemphasize the
importance of consumption and consumerism for people.
So, would you say that Marx was just wrong in his predictions
then? Oh, he was. Like there were things that he was like like
objectively incorrect about. Like the fact that you have to ask
that question kind of just shows that you're not really
Like are you are you the person who should be having this inquisition?
Are you Are you the person?
Yeah, we can look at the world. Marx predicted the total downfall
I think Marx predicted the total downfall of capitalism, right?
Like before it could take over the planet.
I don't know. I just I I shouldn't say that cuz that's like something
I hear people say, but I also have no idea cuz I've never read
read any of it. As far as like economic predictions, like he
thought that like capitalism would like dig its own grave like
really really quickly. He like massively underestimated the extent
to which like it is a resilient like world order that would um
consolidate capital in the hands of like very very few without
there necessarily being a ton of like backlash. I think he like
he presupposed a lot of things about like how people would act
in response to like the contradiction of capitalism becoming
more and more apparent. Um and he did not understand the way
that people would like um I think he like like did not he he
kind of believed that there would be more class consciousness
like as these things happened when I don't think that's true
necessarily correlate unfortunately.
Um I think you can have like massive market values, you can have
all these inefficiencies under capitalism. Like even what happened
under COVID, but people don't seem to think that it's like a
feature of capitalism. They think it's all these other things
that are like causing it or they they they view it as like discrete
failures, but they never think like oh maybe it's just that the
system the like economic world order is not actually set up in
such a way that it enables like the best distribution of goods
like I thought it was supposed to. Maybe it's not as efficient
as I was told. They like think it's all these other things, which
is unfortunate. Um Well, it's efficient. So it's efficient in
that it like huh how could I describe it? It's efficient in that
it follows human desire. People thought probably this is this
actually is very funny cuz it goes back to the conversation we're
having the other day about how like the capitalism works perfectly
so long as human desires are aligned with the the furtherance
of the human race, which for most people they had like pretty
short lives and they loved things that made their lives better.
But now we love things that don't make our lives better. So how
do we how do you
fix capitalism if we love things the most, if basically there
is some consumer good that is sort of like heroin, it like basically
is guaranteed not to help you in any way, and these are the things
like entertainment, like like gambling [__] like
this. What if that starts to become the main focus of our capitalist
capitalistic drive?
Things that are not furthering humanity. So long as capitalism
can be yolked to humanities like growth,
then you're totally fine. When it starts to disconnect from humanities
growth, that's where you run into issues. I don't think this
could really be disagreed with. I think this pretty obvious.
The I think the most interesting thing about Marx was that even
though he was wrong in his predictions,
the That's the fault of consumerism which does not need to be
a part of capitalism. How do you through liberal means get rid
of
Who controls that? People are going to make the thing people
want, right? That's the whole efficient market hypothesis.
How in the world do you The problem is the market
we thought
There are some underlying assumption failures, I think, right?
The philosophy of moderation.
Have you thought about preaching the philosophy of moderation
to heroin addicts, Kuriokos?
Cuz I think that would be very effective. I think you you're
underestimating how much you could do there. If you just started
If you just started prescribing the philosophy of moderation
to heroin addicts, I think that would be very helpful. The The
observations that he was making about capitalism and industrialization
at the time were just 100% spot on. I mean, it was just like
really
unimaginably barbaric conditions for laborers who had like no
collective bargaining rights whatsoever. I mean, often times
laborers were like serfs, violently put down when they were trying
to do any kind of strikes. Um The workforce was entirely replaceable
and so that meant that the the capital owners didn't give a flying
about safety or anything like that. And so in the context of
the time that Marx was alive and he was witnessing these like
squalid conditions, these unimaginable conditions for laborers,
um you know, his observations and his prescriptions make just
a lot more sense. But I don't understand how at this point after
we've seen many many countries try to do, you know, centrally
planned economies and it just never worked out well. Um at what
point do we say like, okay, well, maybe maybe his prescription
was just not right, not correct either. I mean, cuz we have if
we have a situation a situation now where, you know, it's not
that it's not that people are um you know, you talk about people
feeling alienated from from the labor that they do. And and and
um he talked There's layers to the like Marx's idea of alienation,
too. He also talked about being alienated from yourself, like
from your own kind of creative potential, and alienated from
your um like fellow human beings, alienated from like nature
and the environment. See, this is a place I totally disagree
with um the communist types. That like I think communist types
do tend to argue that like creativity can't be can't truly flourish
under capitalism. I actually think it's the opposite.
I I do think capitalism creates the perfect conditions for artistic
creativity to flourish.
I'm I'm not joking. I think I think by far it's like the best
system for that.
So, if if that's an if that's an argument Marx made, I would
totally disagree with that. You see that now. Yeah, but people
like in like a largely like increasingly secular society struggling
to find a sense of community um absent religion, which is unfortunate
cuz there's like should be more like third places and like like,
you know, public spaces like libraries and parks and uh like
schools that should be places where people are more social and
do engage with one another. But instead we have like, you know,
poor urban planning that disincentivizes like walkability or
people really like interacting and like being face-to-face. Like
we're all in these cars that are just horrible to the environment.
Like like it makes uh like living the cost of living very expensive.
Like all of these different ways where like capitalist incentives
have like created a world where like I understand it's very difficult
for people to picture something like different because like you're
saying that alienation doesn't only exist in relation to oneself
and the product of their labor, but it expands and unfortunately
impacts every single facet of their life, even life outside of
the You guys are arguing the current movie industry. Somebody
just said the current movie industry is not a good example of
this. It can be, right? It's only a bad example of it if you
zero in on the past like 10 years.
But I think that I think those conditions are completely untenable.
I think the art that has been getting made in Hollywood specifically
is dog [__] And I think we're fastly we're we're
quickly going to realize that this way of making art doesn't
work and it like had a moment and it is over.
workplace because it's disincentivizing people from being social.
Like I don't like seeing these stats where like people are getting
like like I don't really care so much about marriage but like
people are not like finding a life partner.
I just think so straight away you're arguing that because we
don't have like a renaissance there's it's not equal but I think
there's just different there's there are different creative pursuits.
I would say music has been in like episodically moving forward
in a way that
right? Like music has been moving forward in a way where there
are like major advancements, major diff like different things
happening, right?
So maybe maybe artistically like in terms of drawn or painted
art we're not moving forward but I think that's because those
mediums are just not super appreciated. The mediums that are
super appreciated we see massive movement forward. Look at video
games.
Wouldn't video games be the answer to this? Oh sure. We could
have other things the attention economy absolutely it does. Absolutely
it does. We have certain challenges for sure.
Unfortunately we're video games is
the answer but video games have also hit like a rut I think in
the past like 5
Did you just point me to follow? I did just point you to follow.
Like it's taking like longer and longer for them to do that.
People are like more like increasingly socially awkward. Like
you see higher instances of like mental
I think we've hit a we've hit a rut in the past 10 years in a
lot of creative fields. I do not think that that is indicative
of the way the market will move forward. I think you have to
look on a longer time scale. Unless and that's partially because
we have more awareness of these things but it's also partially
because I like I also think that it corresponds to to something
negative in society. Like I don't doubt that there's probably
even more mental illness now and it's not just a function of
like more people just being aware of it, you know? >> But
the the point the point trying to make is that all of everything
that
you know, it's not that the system itself is perfect. It's not
that everybody feels perfectly rewarded. It's not like we've
eliminated the toxic stress of poverty, especially in America.
There's like way more that we can do to address these problems.
Um it's kind of embarrassing that you have these Nordic states
that, you know, take better care of their citizens than we do
in the richest country on the on the planet. And so And under
a god damn monarchy, which is very embarrassing. Um
>> Cuz a lot of them are still like part of Commonwealths
and stuff. But [snorts] um the point I was making was that the
conditions now for people that do labor like are on on balance
like I'll just say I'll just point out I hate to I hate to criticize
you Aaron cuz you're here in chat. You still have not said this
is not the subject of our debate, right? I understand that it
would sound like running, but I guess I feel like I feel like
I'm frustrated listening to this cuz I I don't I actually don't
care about this. It's like it's it's actually
I will never say that. Ah, I hope I could change your mind on
that cuz I I hate it. I hate it so much.
I hate it so much. It's not It's not good content because Hutch
is not equipped to have the conversation. So we're watching the
the classic Hutch pattern play out multiple times in a And it's
just like
and I don't care about communism debates to begin with. So we'll
we'll keep
Do they eventually get once Lakyn comes in, does he talk about
the Hassan thing? Once once Hutch is talking to a man, will he
actually entertain the debate topic? Or uh the conditions that
Marx was witnessing at the time? Yes. >> I guess I have
I have no clue In some ways because so much of what we enjoy
and consume is literally because of factor like the fact that
those standards persist in other developing countries and we
just exploit their Yeah, but the conditions even in those countries
has significantly improved.
>> Like relative to to where it was it is still it like
it's a significant improvement as far as like like but not only
are it like just to a relative standard like comparing it to
an objective standard of like where workplace conditions ought
to be and human rights standards and like democracy indexes and
like all these different ways like whatever By all those metrics
well by all those metrics though the conditions for laborers
and like what what we used to call like third world countries
or developing nations like have significantly across the board
increased in the last 100 years. Yeah and that's because of liberalism
that like that I don't that's not wrong like Marxists would say
that as well. Free trade globalization like these things have
like produced like very very very good outcomes. It's not there's
not like there's no externalities or negative externalities with
in the form of pollution is like the easiest example for this
or you know like massive oil spills and stuff like that. Planned
obsolescence. You know I would I'm very glad that I was born
in you know 1983 instead of 1783. That sounds like a just an
unimaginably unimaginably difficult life to be born into and
with your system I just don't have a lot of comfort that
your centrally planned economy is going to be able to manage
these Wait I never call wait I don't want central planning. I
don't want central planning. Nationalizing calling for the nationalization
of certain industries is not calling for central planning. I'd
rather move towards market socialism. I don't I don't want there
to be concentration of of power like that much power in the state.
That's like MLs. That's like strictly ML territory which I'm
not. Well how do you do markets without currency?
Well to I want to address other things that you said right now.
Like one I don't think that you should just take a gamble on
my system or like what Contrapoints proposing or anything like
that long term. Like I am the one making the affirmative case
for an entirely different economic order than what people know
and I think people have a rightful skepticism that until the
they You're arguing for like a money-less society. I I feel like
that's you almost have to say it's like in a figurative sense.
There's going to be some way to make sure that you're like not
taking from the system too much that you're not exploiting the
system itself. >> Like you're like That's going to that's
going to imply some form of currency in some way. You call it
credits you could call it whatever the [__] you want.
It's just going to imply some kind of it's going to imply some
kind of money. >> more robust arguments and sort of like
prescriptions and plans for what that's going to look like. I
think given everything that socialism is currently associated
with, which is like despotic regimes, the USSR, Stalin, like
all of these things, like that is a healthy skepticism is one
I encourage and I don't want people to just like take people
at their word, certainly not myself or these things. >> Did
you used to be an ML? Did you used to be more of like a like
the >> No, never.
Oh oh oh, I I feel like I want to Hold on. I see I see somebody
in the chat right now. I just asked Loaderbox if he wants to
talk. Um chat, help me. I'm developing an unhealthy obsession
with these people who have an unhealthy obsession with Hutch's
unhealthy obsession. Hey, we can solve both of our issues at
the same time. Hey Loaderbox, we can we can actually feed this
beast on both ends right now. I have a totally insane obsession
with Hutch. And I would I
I just told her we can feed the demon on both sides. Let's go.
Let's go.
Oh, I thought that was very very cringe. Um and I think that
like those people This is the previous show. The way that they
treat like the theory is like they have there's like an unwillingness
to acknowledge like that these people like Marx, Lenin, Trotsky,
like these figures, like even though some of them made they've
made influential contributions to um Marxism, they're not prophets.
Like there were things that they predicted that were wrong, that
didn't come to fruition and it doesn't mean Marxism BTFO'd. Like
you can acknowledge that there were some some aspects of their
theory are just outdated modes of understanding capital relations
in the 21st century or inadequate and like but like the MLs I
just noticed that there is sort of this tendency to like take
it as like a Bible almost. Like they think that like there's
like kind of only one way to do this. It's it's dogmatic in a
way I don't like. There's like there's a religious reverence
for Marx that I find deeply unsettling, but Marx, when you again,
when you look at the context through which Marx was witnessing
There's I somebody made the joke about the failure of capitalism
that exists
Right? Somebody made a joke about it. And it's very funny to
me
I'm actually witnessing it unironically. Like Hutch is being
massively incentivized to do the exact kind of content he says
he's not obsessed with. He's being massively incentivized to
continue to just not listen and spin around on questions over
and over again,
We're actually seeing it. And they just
I really cannot stress enough how it was for workers back then,
you know, they had no days off, 12-hour days, child >> This
has happened multiple times in the conversation SP. Yes, where
Erin basically says, "Okay, here's an olive branch. I agree with
you on this. We should change this." And Hutch is willing to
dig down on that. And then anytime she makes a point that's relevant
and good, Hutch forgets what he was just listening to and asks
another question. You know, no kind of guarantees of safety or
nothing. Like I mean it was brutal. And like Lenin in the context
of, you know, revolting against the you know, like a brutal monarchy.
I mean he had, you know, the the revolutionaries at the time
had plenty of reason to, you know, get violent at that time.
but I still don't understand like um Oh, wait. She's lying out
of her ass. I DON'T TRUST HER. I DON'T BELIEVE A WORD she says.
I don't trust her. She's lying. She's lying. She's lying.
Again, if this is your belief, if you're going to act like this,
then don't have the conversation.
You can't have a conversation, don't have the conversation.
But you don't believe you can't have the conversation. And Erin's
making concessions here. She's literally going, "Oh, I don't
know how that works. Well, actually, I'd have to think about
that more. Well, actually, um here's like Oh, I agree with you.
There's like a a religious reference for Marx that is totally
inappropriate."
She's lying. SHE'S LYING. SHE'S LYING. OKAY, then why have the
conversation? >> I would have to really quickly and then
we'll let you move on. It was like the everything that you're
going to be like, "Oh, this would like we can't have socialism
or market socialism or communism because what about this? What
about that?" Every everything that Destiny has been so duplicitous
in the past. I don't know anyone believe why anyone believes
the things she says anymore. Well, you're going to point to I
can promise you it exists under capitalism. People just don't
understand as like a criticism of capitalism. Like people are
like oh like bread lines. It's like dude, look at what happened
to our snap benefits for a little bit there. It's clear that
even under capitalism, even under constitutional democracies
and republics with like in developed countries, wealthy countries,
you can still have people like dealing with all of these sorts
of things on mass and like an inability Lonerbox has not responded
to me. Lonerbox, where you at, bro?
I just want I want to talk.
I thought he was talking. Are we done talking? Come on, man.
Let's like both the political will and a desire to address these
things in the short term. Like they're not treated like the crises
that they really really are.
>> Benny Benny's sitting in the discord. I'm not in the
discord right now. Benny's sitting in the discord. He's like
disgusted. I'm going to hop in. Quick quick chat with Benny.
He's sitting here.
Yo, Benny, what's up? How's it going? I'm guessing you're watching
the stream right now? Yeah, yeah, I'm watching the
Okay. What's up? You want to throw a comment in real quick? Well,
I'm going to you know, I um
you know, I want to I want to get all the throat clearing out
of the way, you know, I hate Hodge. I hate all the, you know,
disgusting Destiny writers. But, you know, I'm listening to this
conversation
and I feel like
I feel like Aaron's explanations aren't
moving me any closer to thinking that communism is a good system.
I feel like some of the >> Do you think that might have
anything to do with the fact that she didn't agree to a communism
debate?
Yeah, yeah, it might have to do with that. Um but But also I
don't know I don't know the way that you're responding. Do you
think she wants to? Like do you I feel like when I talked to
her, like do you think
Do you think she's trying to like go out and evangelize communism?
Have you ever watched like her streams? Her streams are talking
about like current politics and stuff, right? I don't think her
purpose is to evangelize communism in any way. So, I wouldn't
be shocked if she's not really looking to do that or or like
effective in doing that. It seems like that is
I don't know, like the intense >> to be fair, this is less
of a criticism of Erin and more of a criticism, I guess, of you.
It feels like your coverage of this conversation is really biased
as if like Hutch is asking the most ridiculous and idiotic questions,
but I feel like if >> Oh, no, no. I can agree that having
the communism debate is >> Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold
on. What do you think my criticism of Hutch is here? Cuz I think
we're missing the >> It's probably something like
he is having he's trying to switch to a communism debate likely
because he's incentivized by Destiny's audience, which is bad
faith. >> Okay, that is That is one criticism. But in terms
of how the conversation is going, my criticism is actually something
different. That he's not really paying attention.
Well, yeah, he's disingenuously engaging the conversation in
a way where when Erin does make a good point, right? He Okay.
He just spins onto another question, and then when Erin does
make a good point, which has happened, right? He digs down further.
He's like ready to dig down further on and and he'll like yeah,
he'll actually start pressing. So, there's just no way to have
this conversation, in my opinion. Like he doesn't he doesn't
want to have a conversation where he understands what Erin thinks.
And realistically, the thing he's actually concerned about with
communism, the thing he's expressed his concern with, is a lack
of respect for liberal democracy. And Erin has said as a first
principle, she has respect for liberal democracy. She doesn't
want to overthrow the democracy, right? So, his entire reason
for pressing lefties and communism in general is already solved.
So, he's just pressing it to press her to get away from the original
So, I'm just continuing to point out that at minimum, I would
expect him to be able to follow what she says and respond appropriately,
but he seems to not be following and he's just getting talking
points from chat. So, it's a [__] conversation to
begin with, right? It's like [__] that he pulled
her in for a different debate. He's not having the actual debate
they agreed to. And then it's also [__] that he's
not even listening to her responses to respond
That like he'll often ask questions that are answered by her
previous response.
So, it's really a criticism of Haz and his ability to engage
in conversation.
Oh, well, okay. Do you think it's that he's too stupid to follow
what's going on or that he is lying? Like that that he's engaging
in bad faith purposely because he just wants to That he's too
stupid He lacks the capacity to have these conversations.
Okay, where does the bad faith come in? Oh, I think he's So,
the bad faith would come in in that he is continually opting
to his chat, so he knows he's not really coming up with the arguments.
Right? He's continually opting to his chat for arguments and
stuff. And I think he's kind of aware that he's not responding
directly. He's kind of aware that he doesn't understand, but
he's continuing the charade anyway.
That's fair. That's fair. And functionally it becomes bad faith
if you even if you're like Do you know what I mean? Like that
you're trying to have a conversation and he's just he's trying
to get like points or dunks? Yeah, yeah. He's like not trying
to understand. Yeah, it's I I think whether he unders- whether
he could understand or not, I think he is trying to get dunks
and just trying to like own the commie, which whatever. I Maybe
maybe you like that. Maybe you think it's really bad, but I just
think his underlying criticism of communism or leftism, whatever
these things are, is the lack of respect for the democracy.
And Straight A's basically answered that repeatedly over and
over again. All of these people literally went out to canvas
with Straight A. All of these people worked in progressive victories
Straight A, and yet everybody is sitting here and pretending
that like Straight A is a commie who wants to destroy democracy.
Why do you think he's Why do you think he's doing that? If if
if his issue with if he's if his stated issue with commies is
that they um don't support liberal democracy and Aaron does,
why do you think he's engaging in this whole charade?
Is it that Is it that his stated reason is not actually how he
feels? Maybe he just hates communism on an ideological level,
or do you think he's just trying to appeal to Destiny's orbit?
I suspect
he doesn't like how Hasan and some people around Hasan have criticized
him. I suspect this is sort of like a
a thinly veiled revenge of of a kind, I suspect. But I I can't
prove that, so I I literally that's what I suspect. Cannot prove
it.
All right. Well,
that's it. That's That's all I had to ask you about. Okay.
Wait, what are you talking about? What's going on? Uh I'm I'm
laughing cuz um
Loner Lonerbox I Lonerbox said I I'm developing an an unhealthy
obsession with these people who have an unhealthy obsession with
Hutch's unhealthy Hasan obsession. And I'm like, "Oh, you're
obsessed with me? I want to talk. So, let's let's feed the demon.
Let's go." And then he was like, "No, I got to go to bed. Bye."
All right. >> Logically easy. Uh he's out.
All right. Thanks for coming on, Benny. See you later. Bye. Bye.
Yeah. I should be clear. I could totally jump down like any communist
throat on how they're implementing like their system. I don't
think Straight Rate has like good concrete plans for how she
gets to
but I don't necessarily think that's what she prepared for or
even like really cares to do considering she seems to think it's
years out in the future.
again, I could totally like try to eviscerate her comments, but
I'm I'm Listen, I have an unhealthy obsession with Hutch and
how he is incapable of intelligent conversation, okay? So, that's
that's what's going on. Maybe you're being bad faith by reading
into his answers with bad intentions.
I'm I'm literally saying he's incapable, and I've literally tried
to point this out multiple times.
Like I I'm saying that he is not capable. Don't hold back. No,
I just don't care to. I think Like I think some of the things
that Hutch has stolen from chat are valid points if like I'm
trying to get you to describe how we get to communism tomorrow.
I think that's pointless given your answers. So, that's why I
wouldn't do that. It's like worthless to me. All right. >> No,
but but it's kind of just like an unfortunate like fact of life
that people see or like they don't understand it to be like an
externality of capitalism. They see it to be like oh, it's just
the Republicans doing this or like just a political party when
it's like it's more complex than that. So, it's my It's my opinion
that like one of the essential functions of government is to
fill in the gaps uh that capitalism has. So, if we didn't have
regulation, if we didn't have social safety nets, if we went
to a more kind of libertarian society, that maybe they don't
have anti-trust laws and you know, power just concentrates until
there's just like one or two corporations or I'm not suggesting
that. Um I don't think that that's a very I think that's just
like has positively Orwellian.
Um Happening now with these like Netflix and like Paramount deals
like that consolidation is like quickly happening right now.
It could be a lot worse. I mean, I take your point, but like
it could could be a lot lot worse if we just if we really had
no kind of regulation in that respect, but um and this particular
problem that I'm telling you about, you know, we kind of do have
solutions. So, like when when when we do have like supply chain
shock and there is inflation, you know, you have liberal democracies
that do have social safety nets. And you mentioned like COVID
and America surprisingly, I'm I kind of can't believe they did
it, but America actually did pretty good in terms of like helping
people stay afloat in 2021. And inflation um got to a point where
people felt that sting, but we kind of avoided total catast-
I mean, like a complete catastrophe. I mean, I think that's a
credit to our system, the way we did it, that we we made it through
a deadly pandemic where people were locked indoors for months
on end basically. And the whole house of cards didn't come crumbling
down. I mean, there were year you know, a year and a half or
2 years >> I'll be honest, I was reading DMs just now,
so I missed the start of this. I don't know how he might be wrong.
I can't I can't actually criticize him on this one. Should I
go back? Is it bad enough that I should go back and listen to
the whole thing again, like 45 sec- 45 to 60 seconds.
I'm going to keep playing for a second. >> inflation and
there's still some problems with the job market right now that
persist from from that time, so we're still kind of recovering
from all that, but I don't know. I think we made it out like
pretty okay. That could have been like a lot worse and um I just
want to go back to the question that I asked you of, you know,
uh with my system, there are kind of you have these supply forces
and they kind of forces this kind of efficiency that just doesn't
really exist in your there's no safeguards in your system. Like
I don't know how to avoid Like my my overall contention with
this conversation is Hutch's problem, the reason you can't have
communists in the in the tent is that they are illiberal.
Strader has said, "Within our lifetime, anything I can advocate
for, we're not getting rid of private property, right? It's way
off in the future." And I personally have an like a first principle
of I will not overthrow a democracy. I don't want to overthrow
a
That solves all of his questions about communism and they move
forward in the conversation, right?
That that should immediately solve all of the concern about capital
or
I I don't know where you go from there. Like I it shouldn't have
gone any further than that. >> just total supply chain
shock if your system with no currency and unlimited access to
luxury items. You said no rationing, no currency. You know, unless
unless No, wait. No, I already conceded that I don't believe
it would it would be um unlimited. That there would be checks
on this, but like I couldn't give you a satisfying answer as
to what those checks would look like as far as distribution of
their good those goods. I only said that there would be existence
of these things as far as like the distribution of them is is
a is still a question to that um is unanswered to me. Did you
say that though? I I asked you if there would be rations. I don't
think you said anything about that. Did you? No, you proposed
you were like, "Would this be some sort of like coupon system
or whatever?" It's like see like that those are the types of
things that like I am like cuz I don't know the answer like I'm
more interested in exploring than it being um it necessarily
corresponding to just how much money you Well, if it's coupon
system, then again, we're just kind of replicating liberal democracy
and capitalism just with more state control. That's what that
sounds like, you know, that sounds like a currency if we're talking
about coupons. If you want to call communism a super liberalism
that only helps me, Hutch, so go for it. >> No, no, I don't
think >> That's not how I see it, but if you think it's
that or whatever. Like if you sleep soundly at night thinking
that, I'm not going to fight you on it. It's >> But I wouldn't
call it super liberalism because I think your system is like
really inefficient in in ways that my system is not, you know.
You're strawman effort. She already said central planning's out.
But I I do agree that like you need some kind of currency. You
obviously have a currency even in a system like this, right?
>> I don't I don't I'm not >> It is inefficient.
Like Hutch, we're at an era >> Or or, you know, I I'll
be fair. I've not seen the philosophical like breakdowns or or
some somebody who's really intelligent breaking down how you
could do it a a moneyless system in a way that satisfies all
of these different needs. Perhaps I could read a like a paper
from somebody and I could be convinced. I have not seen the best
argument mustered from the money the the paper the moneyless
side, okay? Like for a money moneyless society.
A currency-less society. I don't think I'd agree with it, but
hey, it's it is what it is, man. >> like unprecedented
like wealth concentration in the hand of like fewer and fewer
people. Yeah, but there are >> this country Well, that
this is the thing and and this is the This is always true, which
is why you you literally don't have to like my way of handling
this, okay? I do a lot of criticism. I don't do a lot of my own
positive world building. That should concern you. I'm not the
most intelligent person in the room. I like this kind of content.
I like doing it. It's fun.
Know that I am not a person who can like lead a movement, okay?
I don't have a positive I don't have a super awesome positive
vision for how to build my worldview into a future for humanity,
okay? I'm not the leader guy, okay?
But I know that and I'm I'm here. I'm I'm like doing my thing.
That's what this is, okay?
But Hutch is doing the same thing. Hutch is doing the same thing.
He's poking holes. Aaron is trying to build up some positive
idea of her worldview, right? And it's super easy to do that,
to poke holes in it, for anybody. Anybody can do that. It takes
half of the IQ
to poke holes in something that somebody way smarter than you
built, okay? Watch, Trump Trump's done it with the American system.
Just if you need any evidence, okay? It's always the easy It's
always easiest to be on the side of to to be the person criticizing
versus the person being
And one of them is like literally like like a democratically
It's By the way, it's why in any good faith conversation, you
switch off between you switch off like which side is doing the
interrogation, right? The critique.
Because if you're just one-sidedly being critiqued all the time,
that's basically it's impossible to win that over a long period
of time. They elected to to be the president of the United States.
Um I mean I I'm not sure that's like the >> Wait, did she
just make the point that I It is inefficient. Like we're at an
era of like all the presidency like wealth concentration in the
hand of like fewer and fewer people. Yeah, but there are remedies
in this country. One of them is like literally like like a democratically
elected elected to be the president of the United States.
Um I mean I I'm not sure that's like the strongest argument that
your that that my system is like less efficient than yours. It's
not like there are no inefficiencies ever How do we reverse this?
How do we reverse this concentration of wealth in the hands of
the in the one the one percent literally. Well, like half like
the underclass of people like they literally like this concept
this like a few hundred people have the wealth of like millions
and millions of people. How do we reverse this under your system?
I I would tax these people more, you know, I would I would uh
and I would leave it to like I would hire an economic advisor
cuz that's not my field of specialty, but certainly I would be
Hold on.
We We We understand we all understand that if you if you opt
Oh, we just need to tax people more,
are you not are you not just
stealing their private property at that point? If you can defend
that, where's the line now? Here Here's the easy Here Where's
the line now, Hutch? What if I want to tax them 100%?
What if I want to tax them all revenues from their company? What
if I want to tax them out of existence? Well, how do you argue
against that? Uh By the way, the liberal democracy is behind
me on this.
If you believe that you can do that,
If you believe you can do that,
I'm just I'm just saying, if your argument here is taxes and
the liberal democracy like agrees with you, any tax the liberal
democracy agrees to is something you can do, then you have given
people the way to to go and abolish private property without
like uh what do you call it? Subverting the liberal democracy,
right? All I'm saying is if your response is just taxing, could
taxation not simply be high enough that you take all private
property from people?
Or effectively effectively.
Taxes on private property. I'm saying that eventually people
will have to sell their private property. People will have to
do things with their private property to be able to pay the taxes.
I'm saying eventually you can tax people out of having things.
Hold on. You tax what the market can bear. Okay, what if a bunch
of people remove their revenues from the United
What if they remove their revenue streams? They remove all of
their sh- You're in a system right now where a ton of the revenue
of the United States is based on
like services, right? All of those services could just leave
the United States. Okay, so you can only tax what the market
will bear, right?
You can only tax what the market will bear. Well, the market
doesn't bear any more taxes. So, now I ask you again, Hutch,
how do you reverse the wealth
in America?
Exit tax. Okay, well, let's say you exit tax. How are you going
to How How you going to attack any of these revenues? How are
you going to attack the wealth they have? How are you going to
do this, right? I'm It seems like taxing is not the correct response
to reversing the the wealth discrepancy, right? Or you're going
to advocate for taxing in a way that's going to violate the liberal
democracy, or you're going to have the liberal democracy vote
to take a bunch of these people's property that they've
like at the point of a sword.
I It seems like in some way you're going to be violating the
principles you claim to have if your answer to reversing the
wealth inequality is just tax.
We're very much open to taxing taxing the wealthy more and closing
a lot of these loopholes. But I might I might be missing something.
Like I said, I'm not this I'm not the sharpest knife in the >> that
they use to avoid paying taxes. Like the idea that a wealthy
person can take out a loan and the interest rate that they pay
on that loan is less than the taxes that they would pay if they
were to like liquidate some of their assets. That seems like
a crazy loophole. So, you know, but yeah, I would say generally
>> And that's that's where we depart because taxation is
important, yes, but it's the fact that the fact that accumulates
and capitalism has these like boom and bust cycles every so many
years. That is a feature of capitalism. It's not a bug. It is
It is designed and set up in such a way that it enables that
sort of wealth concentration like continually, frequently, and
regulating around it past a certain point. It's like when do
you ask yourself like, is it that we're not taxing enough? Is
it or in that like we constantly have to engage in this sort
of redistribution? Or is it that it is because we enable we like
private property is legal and it is it is it is legal to exploit
people and I mean in the Marxist sense of the of the fact that
like the capitalist is like siphoning off your labor to do >> Well,
your state would I think necessarily have to exploit people as
well. I mean, like I don't I don't otherwise I don't know how
you Well, again, I don't know how you incentivize if the state
needs like really hard labor done. Like a labor that is very
intensive, very repetitive, not very rewarding, you know, like
who's going to want to volunteer for that? You would have to,
you know, order people Well, this is not one-to-one cuz you're
asking specifically about like backbreaking labor in construction,
but like in in our country like doctors are revered as like it's
it's understood as a very very difficult profession even if it's
one that's very rewarding >> Okay. We're back. >> um
hard to do and one that's like like going to it it will take
you away from like your personal life, right? Yeah, yeah. We
have a shortage of doctors and nurses. Meanwhile, look at Cuba,
and this is the only aspect of Cuba that I'm praising. Um, they
have more doctors per capita than literally any other country.
And those doctors are not paid the way that doctors here are
>> This slides 2020 guy just said, wait, is he still in
the chat? He was a little while ago. Hutch is the perfect person
to make liberals keep losing. I hope he becomes more popular.
Well, we're endeavoring to make it so. They were exporting doctors
during COVID to help other countries uh deal with the pandemic.
And you can't necessarily say the same for the United States
to the same scale as like this much smaller country. So, you
have the small example of um, you know, social norms and like
different cultural norms and economies uh leading to incentives
that people just can't really fathom because you don't see them
spring up here in the same way. Well, this is a bit out of my
wheelhouse. I can't really I don't know a lot about Cuba, and
I'm not familiar with the problem of there being like a shortage
of like healthcare workers, but um, I don't know if you've really
engaged in like Um, the My point though, I don't know if you've
actually you know, you say, well, there's got to be some way
to figure it out, it seems like, but >> I don't know. That
seems like a Well, when I asked you a question about how do we
redist- redistribute, you said
Oh, now, hey, I don't think you Listen, I was asking how you
solve this. How How do hard laborers get like paid enough? Well,
I mean, all the same functions work the same way, right? How
How hard is it to do the job? How damaging is it to do the job?
It's like basically saying that some construction worker probably
makes I actually feel like construction workers make about the
appropriate amount of money. Like, um, relatively for what they
do in a lot of cases, okay? But, like, basically, it's a function
of how scarce is the job, how much training did you need to do
the job, how capable, like, how hard is it to get somebody who
could you could train to do the job, right? There's like a whole
bunch of these different things that happen where you determine
how much somebody's paid. It's basically saying that we take
the, you know, how much you could they could how much your boss
can bill your hours out for, and we dial that back to something
more reasonable, right? That's sort of what the ideal would be
here. You could do this under liberalism, too.
It's just like there are some ultimate long-term goals that aren't
compatible, but like you could do all of these things under liberalism.
You're not You're never going to hear from from anyone, I don't
think, that a lot of the things that you'd want to do under like
a communist society, you couldn't do in a liberal society. You
could actually do all of these things. It would just be a matter
of convincing people. >> but like I'm going to hand that
off to an economic advisor. Why can't I just say I'm going to
hand it off to a socialist economic advisor or communist economic
advisor? Cuz they're all left-wing economists or whatever. Like
if I can just default to that, that's the simple answer there,
and then, you know, Well, I mean left-wing economists or whatever.
Like if I can just default to that, that's the simple answer
there, and then, you know, Well, I mean Yeah, but I know we we
we know that taxation works. Like, you know, if we want to, we
can tax wealthy individuals at a much higher marginal tax rate,
and you know, more fully fund like social welfare programs to,
you know, create conditions like a base level of living where
people are not, um, you know, just constantly paralyzed by fear
of going bankrupt for a medical bill or some injury or something
like that. But your system >> know co-ops work? Like we
have data It's limited on on co-ops working and like those sorts
of things, and But I'm not talking about co-ops. I'm talking
about like total supply chain shock in your system. And like
also there's this other problem again where it's like, how do
you incentivize labor that is not rewarding at all? Uh, you know,
like how Are we just looking for volunteers? Do you think people
are just going to be really eager to volunteer for this thing?
I'm just Every time a state has >> like I I So I gave you
my caveat from the start with the Cuba example that I said this
is not exactly a one-to-one, but it's an example of one where
people are like, if you ask most Americans, it's like, would
you be a doctor if you made a salary that's like actually not
that much higher than the majority of professions like that you
can get just from having an undergrad, they'd probably be like,
"No, I'm not going to do that." But like you literally already
see this in other countries. Um, So like it's clear that there
there exists like like people I call it the liberal mind present.
Like they really only think that like only economic incentives
could get people to like do things. And I understand that being
like how people like I wouldn't I'm not surprised that that's
people's like kind of most like based, rooted, deep fundamental
assumptions, but I encourage and challenge them to, uh, look
at countries beyond the United States and uh and see even even
some of these with like horrible regimes like examples of like
systems that have surprisingly like led to more social innovation
than people would previously thought.
Um Not saying that like you got to stand these things or want
them or whatever, but like >> you just give me like can
you give me like a guess? Like, you know, just anything to to
satisfy my question of Could you say something really really
so I can like make a face and get some donations? Hey Straight
Edge, could you say I'm a and then I'm going to make a face into
my camera and I'm going to get like 30 bucks from it. Hey, could
you real just real quick just real for for me for Thank you.
Like how do you incentivize people to do labor that it that is
like back-breaking labor?
It's very funny to watch. So, this is like a good question. How
do you incentivize somebody to do back-breaking labor? Okay,
I would say probably under communism. I'm guessing based on the
job breaking your body down, the job being difficult, you know,
how hard it is to get somebody to do the job, you would pay people
different amounts. You would have to. May Paying them the same
amount under communism doesn't I know that's a I know that's
like a tenant of communism, but obviously there will be things
that are scarce. There will be things that are hard. You will
have to give people extra stuff to incentivize them to do those
things.
No money. The whole money-less thing is Anybody who's like, "Oh,
I want a money-less society." is You need some way to distribute
this stuff and like the whole point is basically somebody cannot
use your labor, exploit it, and make way more money off of it.
That's like the thing you should be optimizing against, right?
Is your labor should be fairly clo- tightly coupled to the output
it produces. Even if even if somebody else has something that
makes your that multiplies your labor, you should have some share
of that multiplier as well. Right? That's the whole point. But
it requires money. It all requires money. I just it's so stupid.
No, if you're if you go to anything but money here, if you go
to anything but money as an incentive, it's just going to all
break back down to money. While you get extra you get extra like
commie slop from the uh from the gruel store, okay? It's like,
okay, I It's all money. Just money is the way to do it. Money
Mercantilism is not something you'll ever move back from. No,
hard hard to say. Hard to say. Because again, like I like we
are this could get back to the little like how much of it can
be >> Wait, did I even use that right? I I mean the idea
of having money, having some I think you that's a part of mercantilism,
but I also mercantilism is like a way of organizing the economy,
too. Just you need money.
Like there is a like a primary assumption in my mind that a significant
amount of that labor would be automated, but it's if it's not,
you know, you've left me with a question that I do think that
I don't have a satisfying answer for you that I need to you know,
maybe look into more theory or see what like leftist economists
are are proposing as as as far as this goes cuz yeah, I do think
it's an unanswered question that I can't seem to give you like
a satisfying answer to, but I want to. So, I think I have homework.
>> I think at that point The funny thing is is if you ask
Hutch how he deals with the illiberalism of Trump, right? Like
basically this is this is something that comes back and it's
very funny because what what if you know Trump is going to defeat
the liberal system, you're going to fall into fascism. Do you
still believe that there's no amount of illiberalism that can
be tolerated, right? You could actually engage Hutch on his beliefs
directly and how they apply to the real world directly right
now, right? Like he has these beliefs. And so, in my
that's the one that's a way better thing to ask, but he would
be equally incapable of answering that question.
And it's far more damning, in my
That that creates like a entirely new dilemma that is probably
more existential, really. Because if you if you have if you devise
a system where people have um now I now I'm I don't I'm not really
sure what you said in terms of like how to um cap like the amount
of luxury goods that people have. You said either a coupon system
or a rationing system. I'm not really sure, but like let's say
you you I don't understand like so this does look make straight
or look bad in this conversation. In my opinion, continue to
sit on the money-less thing. I just don't see why this this idea
of like, "Hey, you have some amount of like
The idea of like currency is just one that is obviously good.
It tries to maintain rates of exchange between all kinds of different
goods. It's like obviously something you would need. If you didn't
have currency, you would still need some way to track like how
to trade or how to barter for things, right? It's just the the
money-less thing is not something you should argue for, probably.
Or I you would have to read into it. Like the whole lack of currency
thing is where he keeps catching you, and it's also like I don't
even know why we're doing it. You can, you know, AI gets just
insanely good, and we can replace literally 95% of jobs. Well,
then you have like a different problem where it's like uh
you know, in the in that kind of situation, in a post-scarcity
situation, you will like plunder the Earth's resources at an
exponentially higher rate. And then at that point it's like,
"Well, how many years do we have left on >> this is This
ties back into what I was saying where I do believe that movement
towards a society like this, I really can't envision it without
there being a Is that's not >> communism, then I'm arguing
for something else entirely. Well, what if one of the underlying
assumptions of communism is the idea that What if one of the
failed assumptions is just that you could do it without money?
It's not that like money is going to be accumu- like you could
come up with ways So, the problems with money, I'm guessing,
are things like accumulation of wealth and all this. You just
come up with ways of like rubber banding that out. So, people
can't do that, right?
No, the money thing is to me like silly.
Also, Aaron, yeah, I did say to argue, but the money thing is
silly to me,
Yeah, I just don't know. It's It seems like the money thing would
be easy. A not concerted, but like there being a really large
de-emphasis on consumerism, and people finding joy and happiness
in things outside of that. And there being actually more joy
found in like some of you know, it's almost as like incredibly
cliche to say this, uh but in things that are totally free. And
don't people spending time with one another and people Oh, I
guess I guess you could just move I guess you could just move
to like well, it's like a post-scarcity society and and it's
space communism. Yeah, sure. You just say the money doesn't go
away until there's literally no reason to track the money anymore.
And that only happens when we're in a place where
literally the only thing like this is another thing is I don't
know I was about to say something. I'm going to
I'm probably never going to look into it. I actually I'm just
going to move on cuz I was going to say like I assume this and
that and that is pointless for me to assume these things without
reading and then I was like well, I'll read No, I'm not going
to ever read this. I don't super care. So I'm just going to hit
play. Uh being outside and engaged in recreational activities
that like just don't really demand that much uh like investment
to to do.
I think it's like it's we're we're so atomized and we're like
people are just so like almost antisocial or the extent to which
like they're social it is like via social media apps. It's like
not in person or with other people that like it's becoming increasingly
hard for people to think of ways that like human beings are entertained
and or find fulfillment like depending on these things. But you
know, there were there's been for as long as the humans have
been alive, we've had a phones and and these sorts of things
for like far less than
How do you think liberals win debates on this? It's actually
the strategy for most people winning debates anywhere is appropriately
applied and emotive skepticism. Literally
the person all these people consider is the is the best debater
in the world. That's his entire game is just freaking the [__]
out at barely innocuous mistakes or something in debates. Hyperbolizing
arguments, right? It's just it's appropriately applied skepticism
to everything. We have had other modes of entertainment and people
were not like literally dying of boredom or anything like that.
People read more. People had better critical thinking skills.
People there were um like to the extent that like literacy was
not as pervasive, it was not uh it was not solely a function
of like poverty or people lacking access to education. It was
because or like sorry, it was more of a function of people lacking
access to education than it was people not like wanting to be
to have higher rates of literacy or like not reading, you know?
Well, listen. I mean I like and I think is getting ready to jump
here in here in a second, but yeah, I mean again I just felt
I feel
I would feel much more comfortable. I mean really when we're
talking about
it was a system that was devised to allow for people to have
these kinds of like creative
these these kinds of freedoms to do their creative pursuits and
to just like do the things that make them happy so they're not
spending, you know, like 14 hours a day living life as a like
a peasant serving under a What? feudal lord or a monarchy.
You know, so like I think my system has actually allowed for
like a lot more of these things and the as far as the >> It
has been the freedom is formal. It's not it's not real. Do you
know what I mean? What's that mean? No, I don't know >> it's
like it's like one of the first things that we talked about.
Like you are legally free to refuse work, but if you want to
survive, you materially are like forced to sell your labor. And
so capitalism actually restricts real like what Marxism understands
to be like true freedom because it forces this dependence on
wage labor. And like, you know, Locke like John Locke is like
the OG lib and like he staked it on like natural rights or whatever
like life, liberty, and pursuit of happiness, consent of the
governed, like limited government.
You know, the state will be there to protect your rights and
if it fails people are going to revolt, which is why you need
these like state apparatuses, but like you should look into to
John Rawls, king of the libs,
a theory of justice cuz he he kind of like replaced like the
Lockean vision of like liberalism for like an updated like 21st
century version. He would have to like ask you. He liked he liked
Rawls. How do you spell the last name? Um r a w l s Okay. Yeah,
I can check him out. But you've heard of like the veil of ignorance,
right? His like thought experiment? No. It was like imagine like
picturing you're designing a society This is brutal. >> society
and you don't know the Go read theory, hodge. Go read Dude. Dude,
these people are so stupid. They heard her say this. They heard
her say this and they're like she think they think that this
person that Erin is currently advocating for Marxist theory or
something. Is Erin not explicitly saying, "Hey, this guy's like
got a better old better vision of like philosophical liberalism?
You should read it." I
But but like but like he she he she's literally saying
"Read liberal theory." Isn't she? Isn't
Is that not what's happening?
Or am I misunderstanding? Is this guy like a covert communist
who who came up with like a different I don't I don't
The race of the person, you don't know the gender, you don't
know their economic status, and you don't know what their talents
are. >> Like create a system that has rules that are fair,
and ensures liberties for these people,
like decreases like significant inequalities, but also like supports
that person being born with like none of those things being advantageous,
whether like you're not a majority power race, whether you're
a woman, you know, or like a like a minority gender, you're a
trans individual, right? Oh, it's never been moreover. It's never
been moreover. God, I love Hutch so much. He'll What the hell?
He's a He's such a genuine thinker and engager.
Dude, I can't. I literally can't. I literally can't. I literally
can't. He wrote down the name of a book he's never going to read.
Yeah, what a genuine thinker and engager. >> Right, mother,
you're impoverished. Hold on. Hold on. I want to pull it back
to like the beginning of Erin explaining what this veil of ignorance
is, and just see how Hutch engages with the veil of ignorance
hypothetical now that Aeradite has named him the good thinker
and engager. I just I have to see. Maybe it's a really Maybe
it's really good. >> rules that are fair.
I'm going to go >> veil of ignorance, right? Like a philosophical
thought experiment? No. Are you aware of the veil of ignorance?
Hutch, the really good good engager, good thinker. Let's see.
>> like imagine like picturing you're designing a society,
and you don't know the race of the person, you don't know the
gender, you don't know their economic status, and you don't know
what their talents are. Like create a system that has rules that
are fair, and ensures liberties for these people,
like decreases like significant inequalities, but also like supports
that person being born with like none of those things being advantageous,
whether like uh I [__] I just I did the thing where
I I DM'd something to somebody. I needed to I DM'd something
to somebody I was not >> know the race of But I Listen,
I'll say I'll say I'm not listening, okay? I'll say I'm not listening
and roll with >> I can check him out. But you've heard
of like the veil of ignorance, right? His like thought experiment.
>> sorry to do that to you guys. It was like imagine like
picturing you're designing a society, and you don't know the
race of the person, you don't know the gender, you don't know
their economic status, and you don't know what their talents
are. Like create a system that has rules that are fair, and ensures
liberties for these people, and um like decreases like significant
inequalities, but also like supports that person being born with
like none of those things being advantageous, whether
you're not a majority power race, whether Basically,
that How do you create a society that optimizes for the most
individual to to ascend to their potential, given whatever their
potential is? So, so somebody who's like literally born in the
lowest class, lowest social rung,
lowest race, lowest everything, how do you design a society that
allows that person to flourish, should they have the capacity
to flourish, right? You're a woman, you know, or like like a
minority, gender, you're a trans individual, right? Whether you're
impoverished, whether you are talented or untalented, a society
that is set up in such a way to even the like lowest of society,
quote unquote, is still has like all of their basic needs met.
That was like his theory of justice, or like the veil of ignorance
thought experiment. And he was like right now, like if you apply
the veil of ignorance to the United States, like it's not like
if you are somebody who is born to like a dentist and a lawyer,
and you're Asian, or and you're born to like a middle-class family
and your talent is like you had piano lessons when you were a
kid or like you're going you're probably going to have like an
okay life. But if you were somebody that was born in like Section
8 housing and you're like a black individual or like you're probably
not going to have like a great life even though we have constitutional
freedoms and capitalism that's supposed to enable all of these
things. Well, at that point it feels like a bit of like are you
familiar with the Nirvana fallacy? Have you heard of
What a great thinker and engager. What a great thinker and engager.
Have you Have you considered that like the thought experiment
proposed by this guy is actually just like
I have but what is it? Remind me.
If something's not perfect it can't be achieved or something?
Um
instead of It's that you accept you you issue the good for for
hoping that you'll eventually find something perfect, right?
That you could have good incremental change now but you issue
that for some perfect future, right? That would be the Nirvana
fallacy. That like you you think that perfect future is coming
so you don't take the good wins you have now. Construct a sort
of hypothetical utopia in your mind of just how the perfect system
would work and then you you compare the current system to that
and it gives you this So such a good thinker and engager.
It's literally a thought experiment. It's literally a thought
experiment. How would you design a society or does your society
like enable this person?
Right? That's that's the thought experiment. It's not something
that can be right or wrong. It's a thought experiment which you
know
just in case anybody's wondering
Hutch did have breakfast this morning, okay? Thank you, Hutch.
I'm glad I That response? You had breakfast this morning Thank
you, Hutch. You had breakfast this morning. Thank you, Hutch.
Thank you. >> This perspective of like oh we live in hell.
But, you know, I would argue if we compare the system that we
have right now to the system that we had 100 years ago, 200 years
ago, 300 years ago, you would undeniably have to reach the conclusion
that despite all the problems that you point out, we are trending
Every single person would agree that given the veil of ignorance,
okay, given this if you're going to put somebody in 17th century
America or 21st century America, that somebody in 21st Wait.
Sorry.
18th century America, I guess. 17 76, 18th century America or
21st century America, okay? If you were choosing, well, obviously
it's better now. Nobody disagrees with that. in a positive direction.
And it's not just like a straight line. There's like um peaks
and valleys.
You know, sometimes >> But it's a general trend upward.
>> Yeah, it's a general trend towards like more freedom,
more prosperity.
And so, I'm I'm comfortable with that trend. And your system
sounds a bit risky to me. I don't know why I would
So, just no engagement at all with that hypothetical. She explained
what it was, and he literally didn't even remotely
engage. He literally didn't even remotely engage. I
I wish I wish
that Shoe could have just said, "Do you want to
Do you want to Do you want to go and explain to me what I just
said to you about the theory of ignorance? What is the theory
of ignorance?"
Or something. Like, okay, and then basically if you even if he
answers, just say, "Okay, why didn't you comment on that? That
like that is the goal of liberalism." By the way, philosophical
underpinning of liberalism, which makes sense. I think all liberals
would agree with that thought experiment, right? That is the
society they want. That's literally the society you want. getting
off that the train now and try your system, which is like
in the way that you describe it totally
And there are some problems in my mind with respect to like >> the
same thing about ushering in
Really they did. Like all all of the same things that you're
bringing up and said it like why not they're like why not keep
feudalism? Like they thought that the system like the like the
wage slave system they were so skeptical of it because feudal
lords were like see when you rent somebody's labor you actually
don't have an incentive to maintain it or like anything when
everything is like rented like this because I have a slave I'm
incentivized to keep this slave alive because if I don't have
slaves I can't enable economic productivity as opposed to you
that you have these wage slaves that come and go and you're just
renting their labor and they don't care about you or your profits
or anything like that. It's a very unstable system. This is why
we need serfs and this is why we need slaves to do all the work
for us because it's like we're incentivized in this way and we
can see to everybody else's needs. But I think the current system
is like >> just rely on us. Like that that was like how
that was the argument that they made against capitalism basically.
Well, we don't have serfs and slaves anymore and people's like
conditions or my material conditions and working conditions are
considerably better and so I would say that you know whatever
concerns people had about capitalism >> this system at
some point and those things will not go away and if they if I
ever thought that they were going away or they were going to
go away I would drop this. I would never Listen, I would never
shut myself off completely to whatever you're suggesting. I would
just need more specifics. Um That's all I ask. I think that's
totally that's a totally reasonable reasonable position. And
again if you think that it's just super liberal liberalism then
again just sleep well at night thinking that it's just super
liberalism and don't be >> no, I think it's like I think
it's like a much much worse liberalism. I think it's like a consider
or like a worse capitalism your system. Not it's not super I
think it's just like a thousand times worse.
We'll see. I mean you could be right. I'm not dogmatically attached
to this. I care about empirics and evidence and if these things
are you know bad if the Nordic countries take a turn for the
worse and you know like we have evidence that like more evidence
comes out that like nationalizing industries providing robust
welfare states in the meantime transitioning to like coops or
market socialism like lead to worse economic outcomes less productivity
make people unhappy I will drop it and I will be capitalism's
number one stand and liberalism's number I speechless I just
super don't care I was actually tweeting to be honest with you
but I just I like it's obviously not engagement at all I'm just
ready to go on to the Iran stuff
like I Iran stand
well listen I enjoy the conversation I'm going to do a bunch
of super chats and then I'm going to speak to like in here but
thanks for coming by
it's it's sad man it's sad it's
every every single argument about not
dude how
I thank god every day that people went down the Hasan is bad
train so that like the people who were like like cultists like
culty DGGers all left the community I thank god that like that's
the way that the progression the community took cuz my god not
dogmatically attached but can't give any specifics
those two don't even remotely they're they're literally orthogonal
they don't remotely touch
what the [__] is this saying this is somebody who
used to be in my community that's why I'm pointing this out
it's just it's so there's literally not an ounce of genuine thought
going into any of this yes he was a mod he was a mod that's why
I'm saying I like I'm just thankful that
that like I I was under I was laboring under the delusion
that these people were here because like I was entertaining or
I I like did Anything here like but it wasn't. That wasn't what
it was ever. So I'm just happy that I the content took a turn.
So all the people who are here who were here for that reason
could be gone.
Holy [__]
Of course sounds good. Few super chats. >> Bye everyone.
All right, bye-bye. Few super chats real quick. Apparently we
should watch a few super chats. >> No food jobs.
Hutch just saw food jobs looking at his 12-year-old cousin. POV
Hutch just saw food jobs looking at his 12-year-old cousin.
No. Wow. Thank you, Hutch. >> Uh All Elite memes with $10.
They were skeptical of capitalism, too. Quote, "Yeah, because
they hadn't seen it done yet. Obviously you'd be skeptical of
something new. Why are we pretending that we don't have centuries
of economic research?" I think that was the point I was trying
to make. Hell Sweet Hell with $20. You will give up your internet.
You will enjoy your homemade candles. Your handmade can- candles.
You will enjoy the same book over and over and over.
Is that a What is that a Is that a uh Oh, uh not so erudite.
Debate Aaron. A meme? Is that a reference to a meme?
Is that the New World Order meme? Uh Hell Sweet Hell with $20.
Sorry, Hutch. Your stream has been deemed unnecessary. You're
getting shipped to the potato Huh. 1980 rules. Yeah, maybe. I
thought Aaron wanted to talk about Hutch's criticism of Rashad.
Just hard for me to care of a communist criticism of liberalism,
especially right now. That's also another good point. Why would
you care about that?
Why would you care? >> No farms.
That's the other thing, too. You I don't know. I like
I'm totally fine with these people saying they don't care. Like
if I'm totally fine with Hutch saying he doesn't care. What I
would not be fine with is Hutch agreeing to a debate on the Rashad
conversation
and then making it a communist conversation. That's all. You
would have to have like
like content creators.
Like what do you do in Aaron's system when, you know, like 75%
of young people want to be social media influencers?
Well, someone's going to have to make the decision of like, okay,
it's going to be this number. And I just I just don't know how
you end up either
with a poor less efficient replication of liberal democracy and
capitalism or just a brutally authoritarian state. Like I I just
it's hard for me to imagine anything
Overlord and Hutch actually reading a theory of justice. I feel
like I want to read it just in case I ever get a conversation
with him and I can subtly refer to things in the book to show
that he didn't read it. I just I feel like it would be very funny
to me, but I'm not going to do that. That's me describing a fantasy.
I'm not going to read a book that I'm not personally I basically
never commit to reading books that other people recommend because
if I ever do that, it like it kills the enjoyment for me or the
interest for me. Like basically if if I tell somebody I'm going
to read a book and I feel like it's a like I've committed to
something, I can't read that book. So. Besides those two outcomes.
Um, Grass Roots Hegemon with $10, I'm getting annoyed at this
woman harping about me paying her rent.
Ho ho, okay.
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Did I miss
Oh, I I didn't miss it. >> Grass Roots Hegemon with $10,
I'm getting annoyed at this woman harping about me paying her
rent. That sounded a
little problematic there. Dos Vedanya with $5.
Uh-huh. Very strong. Very Now, for me personally, I would never
ban somebody from my community for that comment, but that's cuz
I'm a misogynist, okay? I'm an open and about misogynist, okay?
But for Hutch, I would have thought he'd be like, no, no, no,
that's that's actually no, don't do that. Guys, chill. Guys,
don't do that, right? That's fine. That's fine. Boom and bust
cycles do not happen every few years. They are pretty irregular.
They happen, but they aren't necessarily a feature. The other
thing too is like um I I out of my depth here, but you guys tell
me, like people who are more studied on economics,
We'll just restart.
>> So, Erin, you should debate you sorry, not so erudite,
you should debate straighter aid. LOL, maybe, but I'd need to
think about ever platforming her
I had to think about ever platforming her ever.
Uh, quick question, not so erudite, from the time you like from
the time you were friends with her for with straighter aid to
now, what about her political beliefs do you has changed?
Why are you making it about communism? Is that why you don't
have a problem or is that why you have a problem with her? Really?
It's about communism? Were you unaware that she was a communist
before
Why are we trying to make this about
We all know what it's about. Come on, just say what it's about.
I I I think it might be morally wrong for me to platform her.
Not that I think others shouldn't, okay? Uh-huh. Restricted to
the United States,
we could talk about globally, but like has capitalism in the
United States proven itself to be more resilient Okay, I don't
know. Are there more donations? Should we do more donations or
like global disruption like pandemic or
Liking, hello.
Sir, okay, I'm so so so done with this.